e
e e
all right everyone good morning it is
10:02 we're going to get the 10:01 10
o'cl we're going to get the um housing
committee started um with the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America to
the Republic for which stands one nation
God indivisible with liy and jti for
all okay so a couple housekeeping things
before we get started um there's
a there's a few new members of the House
on this committee so um I just wanted to
refer you to a resource that I use to
stay organized as chair but also I feel
like to help the members stay organized
this is our committee flowchart so at
any point you can pull this online um
but you can also pull it from um ask the
committee assistant to print copies I
printed everyone copies of the bills
that are assigned a committee and what
what the status of them are so um that's
for your reference um to stay organized
and I found it very helpful for me um
and then the only other thing is if if
time allows today uh and we have a full
committee I may call an executive
session on a couple bills I've conferred
with um representative Paige on those
bills so um just a heads up there so
don't leave for the the day and not tell
me that'd be great um so with that I
want to open up the the uh public
hearing on HB 572 and call on um
representative stavis um the prime
sponsor welcome
thank you chair Alexander and honorable
members of the committee my name is
Laurel stavis I represent the city of
Lebanon and it is my privilege to
introduce HB 572 to you today the
partners in housing Bill the program
proposed here here tackles
affordability and what's called The
Missing middle New Hampshire has no
shortage of apartment buildings with
rents starting at $2,000 a month or more
and we have a growing inventory of
single family homes approaching the 1
million Mark and Beyond what we don't
have are modestly priced homes that
local developers can build and Working
Families can
afford while we need more homes of all
kinds we need a substantial portion of
those homes to be affordable to the
people who form the Bedrock of our
communities daycare workers Town clerks
teachers firefighters social workers
First Responders and so many
more we don't have these houses because
they don't pencil out for developers the
cost of land of borrowing of
construction and permitting are just too
high Partners in housing takes aim at
these costs in three specific ways first
by offering a database of Municipal and
county-owned land suitable for
development second by providing lowest
loans or grants to developers who work
with municipalities to build entry-level
homes on those sites and third by
Expediting planning Board
review these mechanisms will save
developers hundreds of thousands of
dollars
creating new space for local and
Regional Builders to compete and new
incentives to build the homes New
Hampshire residents so badly need HB
572 provides the investment necessary to
stand up the program and the legislative
framework to make it work all
Investments have to pay off though and
in this case New Hampshire will gain a
growing stock of Ming Miss Missing
middle homes more more funding for towns
when underutilized land starts producing
tax revenue for the first time greater
employee retention for businesses and a
Level Playing Field for local developers
and
Builders Partners will be housed in the
business and economics Affairs division
which continues to make planning
processes more receptive to Home
Building through its successful housing
Champions
program finally there is nothing
mandatory about this program it's a
voluntary partnership that towns and
counties can join if their governing
bodies see fit to do
so in addressing affordability as a key
driver of this problem Partners in
housing could alter the trajectory of
ever increasing home prices and
skyrocketing rentals it will make it
possible for communities to thrive and
businesses to prosper by providing homes
that people can reasonably afford I want
to thank the committee for considering
this proposal and for its crucial work
in finding ways to confront New
Hampshire's housing shortage we're
confident and optimistic that Partners
in housing together with the many other
ideas that come before you this term
will help pull us out of the truly
dangerous situation that we're in I also
want to thank all the individuals and
organizations who support part Partners
in housing and whove been with us since
the
beginning to um housing really it's any
infrastructure that would support
housing
um the program also um would allow Bea
this is one of the other expenses to
create a Statewide database that would
enable municipalities to participate in
putting municipally owned land open for
development on that that would be then
be available for developers to uh
research and and Source um and I'd have
to look to the drafters to see if there
was anything else that um that would be
composed of that I just have a quick
followup oh um so I I think that ex that
explains the grant but in terms of the
loan portion of it how much money is
being lent out who I guess Bea is
lending it who is receiving these
loans so uh it the bill leaves I think
that a little bit open to be defined
through the rules process uh during the
housing Champions program we work with
the um housing Champions um advisory
committee to develop the rules I imagine
there would be another process like that
to be able to narrow down the Loan
program in the housing champions in
invest New Hampshire program last year
we didn't have enough uh funding in the
housing Champions program to focus on
some of the aspects that were listed in
in the legislation and so the rules that
we have were really to focus on what we
did have money for which was the
infrastructure and the per unit so
there's also the aspect of technical
assistance uh which we funded through
basically the HOP program a previous HOP
program which was federally funded and
invest in h and didn't draft uh specific
rules to do that so there would be need
to be a new uh Ru making process to uh
provide more detail on those aspects of
the
program but the eligible uh recipients
are listed uh in the legislation the
proposed
bill I'll say
can can I just ask where in the
legislation that's listed just so I can
look at
it I just have to L my talking points
here the housing Champions program is is
open to municipalities and uh counties
and
developers building Workforce housing
so representative
Paige may I answer I'll answer that
question under um representative's
question there is a portion here where
it says grants and Loans may be made by
the department to housing developers to
whom municipality or County pursuant to
the RC above transfers ownership of the
municipally or County owned property for
the purpose of residential development
where at least 20% of the housing units
to be developed will be affordable for a
period of at least 20 years so in terms
of eligible recipients I think that is
where in the bill we have
that representative Howen I just had a
quick one because you mentioned the
housing uh opportunity grants and so I
think it which I I had asked the
commissioner before just to give a list
of all the ordinances that actually got
passed during the Housing Opportunity
grants because I think it's really
important for everybody to see it it
gives some accountabil ility to show
that the money actually did something um
under this and specifically because
you're going to continue to fund the
housing Champions is there still some
grant money in there to have communities
who haven't reached the point of housing
Champions to to provide them with some
technical assistance so that they can
get to housing
Champions the Housing Opportunity
program there's there I don't believe
there any funds left they just went
through the final round of that uh New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority um
has been managing that program uh that
this would provide additional funding
for technical assistance uh to
communities to continue that um and
let's see the first part of your
question was um I think it was more of a
comment actually that I had asked the
commissioner to provide it it to go out
find a list and I know that hop 2 just
was this fall but if we could see a list
of the ordinances that communities
passed because I I think again we're
we're allocated I think there was
millions of dollars that was allocated
that we can actually see the specific
ordinances just to give us an idea what
we got for our money yep we have a we
have a list that we could compile for
you on that that'd be great if you could
send that to us yeah we did uh because
this does uh connect to the housing
Champions existing legislation um we did
and I think commissioner mentioned this
at the uh last meeting uh we did uh
award 18 communities housing Champions
and we're now in an open Grant process
application process for the
infrastructure and the housing
production Grant
so okay thank you very much for your
testimony okay thank you Margaret
Burns good morning Margaret Burns
representing the new New Hampshire
Municipal Association and we are here
this morning in support of House Bill
572 establishing the partners in housing
program this program builds upon the
housing Champions program that already
exists and it really exemplifies State
local partnership in addressing the
housing crisis while also empowering
local officials and their voters uh to
make decisions that are in the best
interest of the Community nh's member
adopted policies are to create more
local options and more incentives to
municipalities to address zoning and to
take steps to assist in improving
housing opportunities in their
communities um you've heard a lot of
testimony about what the bill does so I
don't think I need to repeat that but
I'm happy to answer any questions if
anyone has any I will note Mr chairman
that you had referenced on page one the
authority to lease uh property I do read
the changes to RSA
411a on page one to really just be
revisions of already existing Authority
not to actually change the authority the
governing body has and when I look at
page two um section five the partners
and housing program and as far as the
grants and loans that are available it
appears that they're available only in
circumstances where there's a transfer
of ownership of the property from the
municipality or the county for the
purpose of residential development so I
don't read this program to also include
leasing of land for a period of time to
be eligible for the grants and Loans but
I'm certainly willing to speak with the
sponsor if that's if I'm
misunderstanding that um so I think that
concludes my testimony I'm happy to take
any questions questions for Miss
Burns you're off the hook thank
you this time right um Bob Quinn
good morning my name is Bob quinnn I am
the CEO of the New Hampshire Association
of Realtors and uh we are supportive of
anything that's going to increase
housing inventory in the state um in
2024 median sale price in New Hampshire
for a single family home was
$514,000 um that was an increase of
about 99.3% from the previous year
nationally housing prices increased 5%
so we were almost twice the national
average um and I think inflation CPI was
about 2.3 so housing prices are
increasing at a far greater rate than
inflation is here in the state um to
underscore that point last week
realtor.com uh released a study and
we've talked about starter homes and the
need for starter homes um so a starter
home as we Define it is a home which is
medium price is half sold above half
sold below starter home would be
75% above above 25% below since the
beginning of covid the starter homes in
New Hampshire have increased
88% um the medium price that is the
highest of any state in the country
according to realtor.com um so the and
the definition of what the number is
that actual number uh for a starter home
in New Hampshire is about
$425,000 um so the the the reason for
the increasing and the problem with
affordability in the state is we just
don't have enough inventory of houses um
and if you look at permitting over the
past 5 Years in New Hampshire you'll see
it's relatively flat um estimates are
that we need about 20,000 new housing
units today to meet the demand um and
that's going to go up to 60,000 I think
before 2030 according to the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority so
um obviously there's a need for programs
we understand there are a number of
programs in the state there's uh invest
New Hampshire housing Champions the new
uh the affordable housing fund all sort
of looking for dollars and there were
dwindling dollars in the state um so we
are very cognizant of that fact I'll
leave you I think that ultimately in
terms of uh resolving the housing
problem in New Hampshire we have to
expand private property rights um and we
need less government regulation in order
to do that and with that I'll conclude
my testimony thank you Mr Quinn
questions represent buo um so thank you
so much for your testimony um I I was
actually really really really uh
surprised and shocked that New Hampshire
has the the highest starter home price I
mean that's really increase or yeah
highest increase so that's really a
wakeup call um in your estimation does
uh is does NH have an estimate about how
many housing units would be needed in
order to sort of restore balance to our
market so right now the estimate and
this is coming from the New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority it's not our
numbers um today if we added 20,000
units um that would meet sort of demand
in December another metric you can use
um there is 1.5 months of housing Supply
uh you want six months 6 months is a
balanced market so buyers and sellers
are sort of on an equal footing um and
we're at 1.5 months so that means that
everything that's on the on the market
today if nothing else came on the market
we would diminish eliminate that Supply
within six weeks um that is remarkably
low uh nationally it's about even though
there's a housing Supply nationally it's
about twice
that follow up yep can I have a followup
um so another question is the existing
housing Supply that we have do you have
sort of an estimation of you know when
that housing was built and who built it
like was it private developers was it a
government program and kind of what
decades was was most of the housing
inventory in I don't have that off top
of my head but I do know that
information does
exist right any other questions thank
you Mr Quinn thank you Ivy
van The
Honorable good morning committee members
I'm Ivy van um I am a certif land use
planner uh nationally I work all over
the United States and I've been working
in New England um and I've been doing a
lot of work in New Hampshire through the
Housing Opportunity planning grant
program I've worked with probably a
dozen towns of varying sizes as small as
Sullivan which I think is 652 people uh
up
through uh Lebanon which is I'm not sure
how how many people Lebanon has but it's
way bigger in any case I'm here to
support this bill uh I wanted to talk a
little bit about why a bill like this is
really important particularly for small
developers in one of my other jobs I am
a faculty member for the incremental
development Alliance which is a
501c3 that works Nationwide to help
people become small developers in their
own places increasing their own net
worth and improving their place
by providing more housing and getting
you know buildings that are not on the
tax rolls back on the tax rolls one of
the things that we see all the time
everywhere is that uh it's very
difficult to make construction pencil
the rubric that we use is that if you're
looking at rental prices for every
dollar that you can realistically expect
to get in rent from a property you
cannot put more than
$100 into creating that unit because if
you do you are an ex developer if you
used your own money you're you know now
you're in the hole if you borrowed the
money from your brother-in-law he's not
speaking to you anymore if you tried to
get it from the bank they laughed at you
so anything that we can do that will
bring down the cost of creating that
unit either by providing land that
belongs to the to the town or city or by
providing grants for the creation of
those units is a help so for example if
uh construction prices in the in New
Hampshire right now are running
somewhere between 3 and a/4 and 375 a
square foot that's 37 $25 a square foot
I am so old that I remember when that
number was
52 uh so if you run the numbers if I'm
trying to build a small unit so suppose
I'm trying to build one of those
cottages and lebanon's cottage courts
and I'm building a 900 square ft two bed
two bath unit or even one bath unit I am
going to be expending just on the
construction something close to
$300,000 so I might be able to sell it
but I sure can't rent it at
$33,000 a month and that's what it works
out to so anything like this that will
allow uh bringing down that initial
Capital outlay so that sale and rental
prices can be lower going forward is a
huge help the thing I'd like to say is
that I think we sometimes forget that
missing middle is a building typology
not a price point um and and we need to
be aware that that's the case that what
we're talking about here is house-sized
multifamilies which will fit into
existing
neighborhoods um I worked on the Lebanon
pattern Zone project and we were very
careful about the way we did the survey
to see what will fit in these
neighborhoods so I would like to urge
the committee to support this bill and
see it through and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you other questions from
Miss fan represent buolo yeah I have a
question thank you thank you everyone
for bearing with me because I have so
many questions because this is such an
important uh topic so you mentioned uh
300 uh you know uh cost of over $300 a
square foot for construction yep um what
are the major factors that have driven
those costs so high what is what is
causing that to be so high land labor
Lumber
laws Lumber is expensive likely to get
more expensive in the immediate future
we don't have enough labor in New
Hampshire we're short on
subcontractors uh that is also likely to
become more difficult uh yeah and of
course uh local zoning laws that require
large lots and have minimum square
footages uh those also and parking which
I'll be back to talk to you later today
about is also part of what drives
it okay and and my followup with this
with this currently proposed bill um
which of those factors does this bill
most strongly address because one of the
things that I'm just caught up on is you
know the $10 million if that is let's
just say loaned out at below Market
rates for developers because it'd be too
risky for a bank they'd laugh at you
like you said apparently you know the
taxpayer could make that risk but that
$10 million if we Factor it out based on
construction cost we could build maybe
27 of these 900 foot Cottages so that's
for $10 million we get 27 units and we
need
23,000 right well all housing is housing
uh the other thing to remember is that
this also allows for the use of of um
municipal owned land so that's a big
that's it right there in my town right
now a lot in town with water and sewer
is going for about
$150,000 um so if we can eliminate the
cost of land that's a big step in the
right direction so and also the fact
that it streamlines the process of
approval for these projects is a huge
help if I've borrowed money from the
bank to build a thing I'm paying for
that money every month and the longer
that you make me wait to do the building
that I'm trying to do the more expensive
that building
is you bet all right thank you very much
for your testimony my pleasure see you
later see you at one o'clock yeah um
last to testify is Stephanie Schuler
hi I'm Stephanie Skyler and I'm with
AARP New Hampshire and I'm representing
our
212,000 212,000 ARP members of the
Granite State and we strongly support
this bill um my experience in housing
includes serving on the board of a
nonprofit housing developer um leading
the workforce Coalition of the greater
Sea Coast and also having the privilege
of serving on the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority for 10 years as as a
board member I'm not going to go through
my entire testimony you can read that at
your leisure I'll just focus on the
highlights and why AARP is interested in
this and AARP is deeply invested in
long-term services and support programs
and understands how housing stability
intersects with caregiving and Community
Health Access to affordable housing
enables family caregivers to remain
close to their loved ones reduce stress
and supports Aging in place Workforce
housing is essential for retaining
service link staff and other critical
Personnel who delivers services that
benefit our most vulnerable
populations I'll stop there and I thank
you very much for your attention and
your service to the state which is
invaluable thank you Miss Skyler um um
any
questions seeing none thank
you okay is there anyone else here to
testify on HB
572 all right seeing now I'm going to
close that public hearing and um recess
for 5 minutes or so to track down
representative new
begin
e e
okay
okay it's 10:45 we're going to get back
started I'm going to open the public
hearing on HB 604 FN and call on the
prime sponsor representative Newell come
on up
welcome thank you chairman Alexander uh
for the record my name is jod n and I
represent chesher 4 um in Keen I'd like
to express my gratitude to you all today
for giving me your time and attention
ition we are at a crisis point we need
23,000 uh housing units immediately not
tomorrow not next year not 5 years we
need it now that's what it would take to
meet the current need at the same time
the number of unhoused individuals and
families continue to grow in much of the
country but particularly here in New
Hampshire we are setting Grim records
year over-ear in order to address this
we've deployed a variety of helpful
programs to facilitate the creation of
housing units in all forms um including
accessory dwelling units however there's
a discrepancy when it comes to
incentives while we invest in programs
to incentivize larger scale development
we do not do the same for accessory
dwelling
units adus are particularly helpful
housing options to a wide variety of our
residents empty nesters looking to
downsize college kids uh young adults
just starting out in careers folks in
the disability community and older folks
living on a f fixed income creating an
Adu can also provide stability for
individuals and families who currently
own a home but are having difficulty
keeping up with Rising
costs I think we can all agree that it
would be better for those securely
housed to be able to stay in their homes
and in their Community if they if they
so choose in fact the prospect of adding
housing stock in this way has many
benefits for many people the lower
income homeowner the renter the
municipality local businesses and
contractors to name a few in my research
and experience both personally and
working with others in the madn region I
have found that accessory dwelling units
are often the only plausible solution of
housing needs in rural communities and
small towns whether where neither the
need or desire for larger Pro projects
exists sure a 2 to four unit um duplex
or or a town home may sound like a good
solution in theory but it is not
economically appealing to a developer in
reality in this context adus are perfect
in some larger cities and towns the need
for affordable housing may be present
but land is at a premium and in order
for a developer to make profit they need
to build bigger and charge higher rents
adus are a great way to bolster uh an
increase in housing there while the
benefits of Adu creation is understood
and many people would like to create one
or maybe even more depending on their
local ordinances uh The Upfront costs
are clearly
prohibitive so let's talk about the
potential solution that I'm
proposing this bill sets out to provide
a structure for a program that would
help bring the cost down specifically
for lower income homeowners so that we
are adding you units to satisfy the
overwhelming need but we're also uh
preventing housed individuals and
families from losing their own
stability the program would re would
require uh rent for the these units to
be at or below the affordable threshold
a descriptor a descriptor that only
applies to 133% of the current housing
stock in New Hampshire to put this in
context in chesher County the best
County just saying um 30% housing cost
for a single person making 80% of the
Ami would translate to $1,400 a month
including
utilities it doesn't exist this would be
the required rent cap on any accelerated
uh accessory dwelling units created by
participants in this program now I think
um I need to address the fiscal note on
this one so I will I think it's a little
presumptuous um in uh flawed in a couple
of ways so just to clarify uh I'd like
to provide a little bit of context
accessory dwelling units vary widely
there are detached adus which is very
which very simply do not share a wall uh
with the main home these can be built
new or be renovated and repurposed
existing structures a garage or a barn
for example then there are attached adus
possibly one of uh many styles of
addition or an attached garage for
example or a unit above the garage they
could even incorporate existing space
that is sectioned off in order to uh add
space to accommodate a full attached
unit considering the vast differences in
the types of projects we're talking
about here I'm really confused at the
numbers we're starting with take for
example the difference between
converting an attached garage with a
shared wet wall and building an entirely
new building the cost of each project
varies as widely as the project itself
and I've spoken with a handful of
contractors and Builders and frankly
these numbers are shocking to
them further it is not my intention here
to necessarily finance an entire project
but to make projects like this feasible
we understand this in terms of
development and in fact we accommodate
it but in that context we don't get 100%
affordable units we usually get
something like 20% that simply does not
meet the need so I'm trying to bring
forward forward a proposal that would so
let's take a minute and think about what
this may look like in practice according
to the New Hampshire fiscal fiscal
policy Institute home values have
increased by 66% in The Last 5 Years
forgive me for the all the numbers I'm
about to say a homer a homeowner um owes
$11,000 on their home after paying it
paying for a few years but the value of
that home has risen by $50,000 above
what they paid given a decent credit
home uh a credit history um this
homeowner could leverage their
investment to access a home equity loan
and they'd be looking at a monthly
payment of about $630 a month based on
8.75 interest rate is what we're at
right now over the course of 10 years at
that rate this homeowner could ensure
that by renting the unit even at an
affordable rate they could cover loan
payments set aside a little for
emergencies and still have money to make
ends meet but if the contractor quotes
100K for the unit that's no longer
feasible if this person is willing but
if this person is willing to rent the
unit at an affordable monthly rate for
that same 10 years and their income
falls into the lower income category
they would qualify for a $50,000
forgivable loan under this
program what I've laid out here are
parameters for a program that would help
folks stay in their home and provide
100% affordable housing units for
renters as they say the devil's in the
details but for goodness sake we need to
think outside the box if we are actually
going to meet the need that we face this
seemed to me like a pretty good place to
start thank you thank you representative
are questions for representative
new representative Howen so when you
envision like the The Loan program would
you uh have more of a sliding scale so
in other words you said this to qualify
you had to have 80% it had to be 80% or
below Ami for rental but if I'm building
a an Adu and I come in and say I'm going
to have my rent at 40% of Ami would in
this forg loan forgiveness program would
you give more money to someone like that
to be a higher need no it's specifically
to be rented as what is considered
affordable and the way that we do that
it it comes from HUD so it's 80% of um
Ami for that area around here it's by
County that's why I talk talked about
you know the best Mon chure and um and
so it would be 30% of that is what is
considered affordable so they would have
to charge that 30% that's yeah yeah yes
I know it's a throwing some numbers
around not usually my
thing um so I have a question regarding
the Forgiveness part of it would would
you consider instead of doing is it a
complete forgiveness of the loan you
would consider or something where the
they would offer it at a at a lower
interest rate I guess I'm I'm wondering
about the state's ability to recoup some
of the cost of this so it's not just a
handout and it shall be forgiven but you
know maybe they can create like a
revolving fund for this sort of thing um
where they can slowly you know build up
the fund I guess I'm wondering what what
your thoughts on that is I think um I
think anything that we do will be
helpful number one I'll just put it like
that anything that we do to be able to
make it more affordable I think will be
helpful but what I hit envisioned with
this is to say for example you factor
out a you know a 20-year um repayment
plan right if you do this for 10 years
you've satisfied it and your loan will
be forgiven or um if it's combined with
something else you can defer the
payments so I I think there are a
variety of ways we can go about it this
is why I say about the devil in the
details I think I'm really trying to
provide a structure and a goal and then
hopefully be able to work with folks to
figure out exactly what that would look
like and still be um yeah helpful thank
you represent re thank you Mr chair uh
thank you for your testimony is I have a
followup after this is it fair to say
that not only would something like this
uh incentivize people to build
affordable housing which we desperately
need that missing mle that we previously
talked about but actually in that
process because we're helping them
generate a revenue source for themselves
we're helping lift that lower um LMI
population I guess it might just be 80%
might be just lowincome population up
isn't that accurate absolutely uh am I
followup yep thank you uh were you aware
per the chair's comments just now about
a revolving fund that there was a bill
last year um that would have created a
loan program that was self- sustaining
um to help people uh purchase uh
affordable housing and that type of
program in that bill might fit in well
with this um because if a private
institution can make money lending out
loans for people to have housing then
why can't the state do that at um at
Cost I
agree great other questions for
Representative no seeing none thank
you
um Nick Norman
thank you once again for the opportunity
to speak um we've looked at this one and
actually don't have an opinion for our
against there's as we read through it we
see some pros and cons so I just want to
mention those and there are some
technical things that uh I see as an
issue with the way that some of the
language is written um certainly it
would be a benefit to have more housing
and we're all for creation of more
housing so incentivizing that is a good
idea there are some in our membership
that think that it's um too much of a
cost for the state the taxpayers to pay
through the state to benefit a few
individuals I'm not saying that's my
opinion there's just varying thoughts on
that there's I think a very troubling
piece of the way that this is written if
you look at line page one line 24 it
just talks about the ability to forgive
the loan and to forgive the loan it
would have to be
rented at the affordable lower income
household rates for the duration of the
loan term so the way it's written it
sounds like someone's renting that
property they lose their
income or their incomes greatly reduced
well to keep the the Forgiveness piece
here then you'd have to lower the rent
to whatever their existing income is
now so it would make it totally
unworkable the way that that's written
you could you could write it in another
way that the lease you know was it was
rented at the start of the lease and
then whatever happens well that that's
the way life happens but the way that's
written you know like someone could
totally lose their income U be existing
on benefits and support and the rent
would have to be brought to zero or some
extremely low number just to keep the
Forgiveness portion
active um the other one is that
there's I think it's the next
page um anyway it talks about the loan
term this would have to be kept for the
loan term but the loan term is not
defined
so I I don't know what that
means so something needs I would think
something would need to be done to
Define what that loan term would be um
that's my only comments I'd be happy to
take any questions thank you
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in to testify this morning in
regard to the possibility of a tenant
losing their income and then the rate uh
the rent rate being based on that income
isn't isn't the the calculation of
affordability based on the HUD
definition of affordability and the HUD
definition of lower income households
which is 80% of the Ami for the county
not it isn't it not based on the
individual tenants income but rather on
that 80% of
Ami I see your point i' have to think
about that that that that might answer
the
question thank you thank you
representative Gibbs other
questions seeing none thank
you and my apologies representative
Damon I didn't see you before but come
on
up good morning no apology needed
representative or chair Alex sander um
and thank you committee for the record
I'm representative hope Damon I
represent Sullivan County District 8
towns of aworth Langdon lemster Goan
Washington Springfield sunap my hometown
of Cen and the City of Claremont where
there is a lot of Need for affordable
housing and a largely over the
district very modest socioeconomic
status there are many folks who could
benefit from this creative
bill um and I would comment with a
cliche um this to me is is like the give
a man a fish or teach them how to fish
help somebody have Revenue to stay in
their home and they will continue to be
able to be there and be a property
taxpayer and in many cases a person
working in our business economy that we
very much need those employees
especially Sullivan County is growing we
have increasing need in industry and we
want people to be able to live
there um I want to just mention a very
recent I think it was a couple days ago
note from a
constituent who said
essentially my wife and I have two um
upper middle
inome uh professional positions we have
saved a sizable down payment and we are
$100,000 under budget for any home we
can find to buy anywhere near where we
work in Sullivan
County if they were able to purchase a
property and put an Adu in they could
have rental income to subsidize their
mortgage and they are not unique in that
um the other point that I would make is
I want to reinforce represent of n's
introductory remarks regarding the
variation cost to create
adus so as the spouse of a longtime
residential building contractor who
mostly did Renovations and
remodeling uh often on old or older
homes I kind of have a personal resource
on approaches to construction and ways
to mitigate costs and as I talked with
George about this bill and said you know
in this market Labor's expensive
materials are expensive would it really
cost this much on average for an
Adu his perspective was very much not
necessarily depends on all the Myriad of
decisions that you make in both the
design process and what you do there are
a lot of ways to reduce costs um for
example putting a bathroom and a kitchen
very close to the existing Plumbing is a
whole lot less expensive than if you put
it on the other side of your mod size
Adu and you've got a lot more work to do
and a lot uh more material cost um great
variation in the cost of cabinets Etc I
will not take the committee's time
itemizing that but I think that
homeowners who are interested in doing
this could certainly get good quality
advice to help them do it for more like
$100,000 if it's within the existing
building um so I would very much
encourage the committee to reinterpret
the fiscal note with a range of costs
for creating
adus um and I will just State my strong
support and then I will Boogie Back to
education funding committee where we are
trying to figure out how to lower
property
taxes well thank you for doing that um
any questions for representative Damon
Sean thank you have a good day you as
well Jack rman
morning Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Jack rudderman with New
Hampshire housing I am our energy and
legislative affairs
advisor um I want to start out by saying
we are very bullish on
adus our job is to fill the housing Gap
in New Hampshire and that's going to
take
um a variety of solutions there's no
single you know no Silver Bullet um it's
the old silver Buckshot um and so adus
are one of our top three legislative
priorities the session um we have
commissioned studies on adus we have
produced fact sheets on adus we have
convened conferences uh on
adus so we are very much in favor of a
meure um that will increase the ability
of um of folks uh in existing homes um
to create adus or uh folks who may maybe
want to downsize and live in an Adu next
to family members house for instance um
on the issue of construction
costs our numbers were based on the
assumption that you would be creating a
freestanding detached unit or new
construction attached unit um as IV van
testified construction prices are
insanely High um
and she noted that prices right now um
range from 325 to
$375 per square foot um for our purposes
we estimated 275 to 300 per square foot
um
putting together a a new Adu is a very
costly Endeavor and uh we stand by our
estimate of a new freestanding unit
costing 275,000 to 300,000 and I think
in some ways that may actually be a
little bit conservative however the
point that not all adus fit that mold uh
is well taken and yes you could have a
garage uh and you just need to put a
bedroom uh kitchen at um and plumbing um
above that unit and sure that might cost
100,000 so um I would you know readily
acknowledge um that we picked one data
point and it probably is a better idea
to use a variety of data points um
so the cost could be 100,000 I would say
to 300
325,000 depending on the type of Adu and
choices that are made but I will say
that you know choices such as you know
cabinets and going with something less
expensive like Ikea like folks are
already doing that um people aren't
building luxury adus as as far as we
know um so uh again we support having a
program like this it's important to note
as the chair did um that the way this
bill is written this is essentially a
great program um and the funding for
that has to come from somewhere um so
the the suggestion that perhaps it be a
revolving Loan Fund I think is something
we would be um very open to and with
that I'm happy to take any questions
questions for Mr Rudman represent bolo I
have a question so um yeah thank you for
your testimony and um I I agree with you
Adu is being part of you know one of the
things that New Hampshire can do to
really help solve our housing crisis
um in terms of uh impediments to
building adus what do you think would be
maybe the most effective strategy what
would be the one thing that you know the
legislature could do to increase the
amount of
adus uh that would be a bill um
loosening some of the restrictions on
adus and there is such a bill that the
chairman uh is a sponsor of um that this
committee I'm sure will be
hearing um and it's you know a pretty
Broad and comprehensive Bill basically
looking at the Adu law that was passed
eight or 10 years ago which was
something we actually were very
supportive of and and helped um draft um
so I think a new bill saying okay it's
been eight years or 10 years um let's
allow detached units by right um not by
special exception um and let's let
everybody as a right have one Adu
whether it's attached or detached uh and
and various other sort of technical
fixes um and things to um just make the
process easier so we're very much
looking at at that bill as a top
priority all right thank you for your
testimony thank you uh Stephanie Skyler
Stephanie Skyler still with AARP and uh
we support HB
604 um once again I'll just talk about
the highlights since I'm passing around
U my written testimony and we believe
adus pay a critical role in addressing
housing affordability and promoting
Community well-being by allowing low
income homeowners to create additional
Living Spaces in the property this bill
would support family caregivers ad adus
are a vital tool for unpaid family
caregivers who often need flexible
nearby Housing Solutions to care for
aging parents relatives with
disabilities or loved ones recovering
from illness the ability to build or
renovate an Adu enables caregivers to
provide highquality close proximity care
without significantly dis disrupting
their own
lives adus also facilitate Aging in
place many older adults wish to remain
in their communities as they age adus
provide an ideal Solution by allowing
seniors to downsize while staying close
to their families and familiar
neighborhoods renovating existing
structures into adus can also ensure
more accessibility and safety helping
older adults maintain their independence
for as long as
possible a us also strengthen
intergenerational living they promote
Arrangements where family members can
live together or nearby while
maintaining their privacy the
arrangement supports stronger family
bonds and enhances emotional and
financial
stability and another thing adus do is
expand affordable housing options adus
provide an opportunity for homeowners to
generate supplemental income through
rentals while simultaneously offering
affordable housing options to
tenants and lastly adus address
Workforce housing needs by expanding the
housing Supply particularly in areas
with limited affordable housing options
adus help address Workforce housing
shortages and Foster vibrant sustainable
communities for these reasons and so
many others ad um AARP supports this
Bill thank you thank you Miss Skyler for
your testimony any questions seeing none
thank
you and last on this bill is I
van good morning again committee I'm
still iiv van I'm still a planner uh one
thing that I was thinking about when I
was listening to the testimony on this
bill and the question about you know is
this really a gr program is I would urge
the uh drafters and the committee as you
think about working on this bill to take
a look at Millar Vermont's program for
accessory dwelling units um I think the
planner and Miller is Michael Miller I
think he's still the planner uh Miller
put together a program
probably was before the pandemic so
probably five years ago where they
appropriated you know a half a million
dollars at town meeting and put it into
a revolving Loan Fund for this very
purpose for the for creating accessory
dwelling units and one of the ways that
they structured it is that if the
property were sold at the time of the
sale the loan would be repaid so that
might be a model that would be worth
looking at um otherwise I'd say that
anything that gets adus built is a good
thing um they're not the cheapest
solution but they are a very good
solution I would be cautious about
structuring this in such a way that the
homeowner doesn't really realize any
benefit from the Adu in terms of
financial recompense um one of the
things I see a lot as a planner working
in New England is that we've got a lot
of little old ladies and I can say that
because I am one um we've got a lot of
little old ladies living in houses that
are way too big for them and they you
know they can't keep paining on the
house they can barely pay the taxes if
they put it in Adu they need to get some
of the benefit of that money um of that
of that action so those are things that
I'd like to offer the committee as they
think about this project going forward
anything we can do to get more housing
units built is worth doing housing is
housing thanks happy to take any
questions uh so miss van you're you're
talking about specifically removing
the a Ami determinants and all that
stuff and just creating a a revolving
fund creating a revolving fund and um I
would so the whole a right now Workforce
housing is 60% of Ami area median income
um if you said that I what I'd like to
see avoided is that the homeowner
doesn't get anything so that uh if
they're if they're renting at let's
think about numbers here so suppose they
get a loan for $100,000 to build this
and they are renting it out at 80% of
Ami which is low
income um they should be able
to they should be able to keep some of
that money do you see so that they're
not just providing this for
nothing and I I guess what you're saying
is it it ties their hands if they're
being told they can only rent at a
certain exactly I think you should put a
top on it but I think that top should be
high enough so that they actually
generate some income from it because
otherwise why would you do this I mean
um
yeah it is not without personal cost to
do thank you okay thanks so much thank
you is there any is there anyone else
that wish to testify on HB 604
seeing now I'm going to close the public
hearing um the committee will be in
recess until 11:30 at that point we will
exact um three bills so um we're recess
for about 15
minutes
e
e e
okay I'm going to call the housing
committee back to order we're going to
go into executive session um the first
bill on the agenda that I'd like to exec
is House Bill
65 um I will entertain myself for a
motion who will move that we retain
House Bill 65 is there a
second second by representative miles um
just to talk about this a little bit um
I I think when we heard during public
testimony there isn't Broad disagreement
that there's no good merits to the bill
I think there's things that we can work
on as a committee I think it will
require um some time over the summer to
do that and you know if we decide in the
summer that we can't get to a consensus
or we can't figure it out then we have
options next fall but I think I want to
give the time to this bill that it
deserves and we can retain it over the
summer get some hopefully get some good
work done by partisan work and U move
forward but I think the bill as written
is
unworkable any other discussion on
that um IO I would just second those
comments the other thing I would think
that would make sense to retain this
bill is there's also as I understand the
uh justice department um had a
settlement um with a couple major
commercial landlords uh throughout the
country and the Crux of that was they
were all sharing information about what
different rents were being charged so
maybe also give it some time to see what
the implications are from
that other discussion on that
representative Paige I support this
approach um and I just want to share
with my caucus that I I did have a good
chat with the sponsor who's also in
agreement this is a desirable way to
go okay anything else all right um the
motion is retained I'm going to have the
clerk um call
roll Vice chairman Cole
yes representative
Thaxton representative Aaron yes
representative bullier yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative miles
yes representative Miner yes clerk
reinford yes representative paage yes
representative boras yes representative
Reed is not in the room representative
Gibbs
yes representative Hicks yes
representative Howland yes
representative hegner yes representative
Kerwin yes vote
passes oh sorry chairman Alexander
yes I can vote this time yes so motion
passes um 17
to0 um we don't need to write a report
on this cuz it's still in the
committee's hands so this will not go on
the floor for a vote um this is going to
be in the committee's hands throughout
the summer um the next bill on the list
I'd like to pull up is House Bill 60 and
I will um call on representative baxton
for a motion uh I move that we move this
bill forward with an ought to pass ought
to pass by representative Daxton is
there a second I'll second
representative Dumont seconds it um
representative Daxton would you like to
speak to your
motion I think that this bill has passed
the house on several occasions I think
it's a sound bill and I think that it uh
Works to expand the opportunity for
people to invest in real estate on a
small basis and provide better housing
opportunities throughout the state of
New
Hampshire other comments on this bill
representative Howen so so I understand
actually uh the the need for development
especially for developers to to be able
to recoup their cost my my real con
concern really was um is we have a good
cause for eviction but under the there's
really no good cause for like renewal of
lease really written in and so I think
it was alluded to up here that only like
133% of uh renters median income you
know if you took median income of all
the renters only 133% of them actually
can afford a two bedroom apartment and
that just speaks to how many people are
rent burdened and so two months really
is not enough time for them if they're
if it's sudden and you're a renter and
that comes up you don't have enough time
or security deposit to come up with uh
with the money to come up with a new
apartment and I think Crossroads
mentioned it's about aund and $20 a day
uh to to house somebody that's lost
their housing and so I just think the
way it's worked there's not enough
notification so it it I want a better
balance that helps the landlords but
also gives better um notification to the
tenants and so I don't think this bill
does it so that's why I can't support
it representative Paige thank you Mr
chair um I can't I can't support this
bill either um and I keep I understand
in
principle why one could support this
bill and I I understand as a landlord
myself who has lived some of these
issues on that side of it uh um I
understand as somebody who has talked to
folks trying to go through an eviction
process and the challenge that that
presents so I get it I get why it seems
desirable but then I also have to hear
in my head The Echoes of everyone who
came to
testify uh New Hampshire housing the
Coalition and
homelessness um the our local welfare
agencies and
person after person came up and
testified and said very
clearly this is going to drive
additional homelessness in our state and
for
me you know setting aside the principle
which I understand the Practical reality
of this bill as I see it is we're going
to put more people into homelessness and
it's folks in every one of our districts
you know it's moms and their kids living
out of the car it's you know seniors up
in the north country where I am who are
living in tents in the woods um and we
already have a real
epidemic
and at this moment in time I just
personally feel that this change is is
irresponsible so that's where I am
coming from on this
bill representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair I also can't
support this bill uh I do understand the
argument uh for fairness to the landlord
in terms of the equal understanding of
the contract between tenant and landlord
but in the current housing market with
the difficulty of finding any Apartments
let alone affordable
apartments um the risk of putting people
on the street of evicting without good
cause and people the result being that
people are homeless I'm just not willing
to um support that
risk thank you representative
representative
um I think we're using the word eviction
irresponsibly this is not an eviction
process this is the termination of a
contract um just so on my end I mean
this to add on to that this is a lease
this is a contract that was signed for a
specific amount of time um it's it's a
property rights issue and I think the
what's important is we we noted that you
know housing providers do not want to go
through finding a new tenant that's not
like their top priority it's actually
very expensive for them to do that
between application costs and other
things so they wouldn't use this as a
way to you know they wouldn't use this
to to get rid of a tenant they would use
this um if if the situation they they
they they would only use it if it was
needed and they want to keep they want
to keep good tenants in their in their
houses and and if it's their property
they should be able to do what they want
with it and I think that's where I come
from on
represent paig I guess my question
following from that
is you know they're only going to use it
when they need it what is the need you
know we have these other good cause
reasons for eviction which I support of
course there are there are reasons but
you know is it just a personal
disagreement with the tenant that you
don't like the tenant that to me raises
all kinds of issues you know you're
saying it's to get rid of a bad tenant
well that's why we have eviction for
cause um so you know I see this
as a a way to skirt that right it's sort
of okay well I'm instead of going
through this process of an eviction I'm
just going to wait the three months for
the lease to be up and then I'm going to
evict them for these reasons but I am
going to use this as a workaround I mean
that's what I see this bill doing
represent buolo thank you Mr chairman um
you know with this and during the
testimony I mean my heart really goes
out to people because a lot of these are
we're hearing testimony of people who
are really suffering because of New
Hampshire's housing crisis and I think
we've also heard from the the testimony
that this housing crisis is I think the
legislative environment the legislature
in past sessions is partly to blame for
the laws that we have and I think that
you know there's a lot of laws that are
made you know to maybe try to address a
problem or because there's this very
very strong emotional appeal but the
long-term consequences of some of these
laws can really really really be dire so
I think that if this bill um were to not
pass I think what would happen is you
would you would not fix the fundamental
problem all that heart-wrenching
testimony those people would still be
facing High rents they would still be
facing housing uncertainty we'd still
have escalating homelessness and
actually in fact you'd have a lot of
housing providers who would be dissuaded
from putting their property up because
they' think W man but if I have a
problem tenant they're going to be
really difficult to get rid of or I'm
going to have to go have good cause or
I'm going to have to go to court which
is an expensive time-consuming and
intimidating process especially for the
small mom and pop housing providers so I
think the net effect of this not passing
will be a continuation of the housing
crisis it will not help any of the
people who were facing possible
evictions and it actually probably could
make it more difficult um in the
testimony one of the questions I asked
was would if this bill would pass would
it make it easier for housing providers
to provide housing would it encourage
that and the answer is yes so I think
let's do things which align incentives
and allow people to provide
housing representative um Dumont and
then representative
Howland I just want to say as as real
estate broker a developer and a landlord
one thing that I've always seen is that
what always makes for a successful
relationship is when a contract is fair
and equal on both sides and I would say
that this would allow both sides to come
to the table and renegotiate a contract
to benefit both parties with more notice
rather than a landlord just serving a
30-day eviction
notice representen so um I I think I
probably everybody hopefully is in
agreement that the best thing is to have
a tenant on a contract every you know
you really want your tenant on a
contract I think what really struck me
was the lawyer who came up here and
talked about how many people are
actually off the contract more at will
and month to month and you you never
want the month to month because it's bad
for a landlord because it it it's
uncertainty to the landlord and it's bad
for the ten tenant because it gives
uncertainty to them and so that's why I
keep coming back to the notification it
it's better if if if the landlord is uh
not waiting till 60 days before the
contract is over but there's more
notification particularly if a tenant
has shown good cause if you've paid your
rent for say six months you've been a
good tenant you haven't caused any
problems that the landlord is able to
exercise more of an an option to say
look you're a great tenant you've
already said it's expensive to replace
them why not give more notification to
the tenant maybe at the six-month level
saying look would you like to renew the
lease it's going to cost this much more
money is that feasible that way it
provide certainty to the landlord they
know if the tenant says yes I can I can
do it and you're going to renew the
lease and there's no time with the
tenants off the lease but by the same
token if the tenants one of those rent
uh stressed people and you say no your
your rent's going to go up
$200 the person says no I can't afford
it there's a longer time period for the
tenant to work with some of the social
agencies to figure out where they are
where they are so that we don't get to
the end of the lease and the person is
like suddenly left hanging so I I'm not
sure how to actually work that out in
there but I think that's what we're
really trying to
achieve representative Kerwin I just
want to add to that that I feel that um
like uh representative howand was saying
that in this housing market you could
have good tenants who have paid the rent
the whole the whole term of the lease
and when the lease ends they cannot
afford the um increase in rent but they
in that short period of time they will
not be able to find housing again and
then the eviction process will start and
they will have an eviction and which
will make it even harder to find housing
so I am concerned that especially in
this housing market it is not possible
to find an apartment that
quickly represent
minor if their rent was increased in
that short of a notice they would end up
with a 30-day the lease would be over
and they would be a tenant at will at
that point and they would get a 30-day
only notice for an eviction well a 7-Day
notice if they couldn't pay the
increment and then be out within about
30 days anyways and also with the lease
they have one year's notice they don't
have 60 days they know that it could
possibly end in a year so maybe if we
could all as a tenant even could do
their due diligence and go to the
landlord and say hey my contract's up in
six months uh what's going to happen do
you have any idea instead of the
landlord having to have the burden to go
talk to
them represent Von I just want to
reiterate the point that representative
Miner made
under the current Rules of Engagement
between a landlord and a
tenant a landlord can raise the rent at
the give 30 days notice at the end of
the 11th month and raise their rent
50% and they're gone they have less
notice than you would have under this
bill and it it's terribly unfair to the
small property owner and 73% of rental
properties in New Hampshire are owned by
small owners and individuals who own
less than four units and they're not
versed in the fancy ways of the law and
the legislature they are very average
people who think they signed a contract
for a year and at the end of the year
you should be able to say you I got
something else I want to do with my
property and there's also a a failure in
the logic that we're all listening to in
here there's nothing in this bill that
says and now the housing unit has gone
away it's simply going to the next
person in the housing
queue and most as a practical matter as
a landlord and as a property manager
there are turnover costs so if I'm
looking at somewhere between
$255,000 in turnover costs which seems
to be where we're at right now because
as lady said earlier Lumber is
expensive if I'm looking at those costs
I'm not looking to willy-nilly throw
people out so I've got to have a
motivating reason to terminate a
tency just my thoughts I think that
you're giving people with 60 days notice
you're giving them more notice than they
have now and you're giving a Far More
Level Playing Field between the average
property owner in this state and the
average tenant
representative Aaron I just want to Echo
what representative Miner said it's a
two-way street the tenant has every
right currently and after this
legislation is passed to go to the
landlord and say hey my lease is up in 4
months three months can we renew it so
there's nothing to stop the tenant from
doing that if I was a tenant I'd be on
top of my lease
period other comments about this
represent page I just I I just want to
resurface
um one comment that was made in
testimony that I found disturbing about
this um and I recognized that
retaliation is illegal now and will
remain illegal after this passes but
when the lawyer from NH legal assistance
was testifying and talking about how she
would counsel her clients should this
pass I found that to be Illuminating and
disturbing that you know if if she were
if she were providing counsel to a
client who were a victim of retaliatory
action and they were evicted under this
law should it pass that her advice would
basically be tough luck like you're out
because the end of it's the end of your
lease term there's really nothing we can
do even if it was secretly motivated by
a retal
retaliatory um as a retaliatory action
and I I find that unsettling and I just
want that stated for the record
representa
Axton so if this law were to pass the
meter if if if I if I as a landl Lord
provided notice to a tenant 60 days
before in compliance with all the forms
here and said and now on June 30th the
that's the end of your tency you need to
go if the tenant does not go I then have
to go through the normal eviction
process at at the court I have to give
them a demand I have to post an eviction
notice I have to give them seven days to
perform if they fail to do that then I
have to go to the sheriff have the
sheriff serve them and then we have a
hearing and the judge judges in this
state still have a 90-day discretionary
there's nothing in this law that changes
it the judge still has the a 90-day
discretionary Stay on any eviction so
which obviously are you know they're
taken on a case-by Case basis sometimes
it's right away mostly it's 60 or 90
days the point is we're not we're not
taking anything away from the tenants
that they don't currently have what we
are doing is we are giving an option or
returning a right back to the property
owner to say our contract is over I
don't want to renegotiate I want to move
on so potentially
and the way I read this bill if if a
tenant If a landlord properly gives a
60-day notice at the end of the bill
there's up you're really looking at a
femon period based on going to court if
the person if the tenant says I'm happy
to go there's really nothing to discuss
it's not an eviction it's just the end
of the contract and so I think a
disproportionate amount of uh discussion
has been made on how this is a terrible
thing and an eviction it only becomes an
eviction when when I have to go to court
and I have to have the court beat you
into leaving my
property okay seeing nothing else I'm
going to uh have the clerk call the roll
the motion is ought to pass by
representative Daxton second by
representative
Dumont Vice chairman Cole
yes representative
Faxton yes representative Aaron yes
representative bullier yes yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative miles yes
representative Miner yes clerk reinford
yes representative Paige no
Representative boras
no representative Reid not present
representative Gibbs
no representative Hicks
no representative howand
no Representative hegner no
representative Kerwin
no chairman Alexander
yes
so motion passes 10 to 7 to1 um
representative Daxton will you write the
majority report and um is there someone
from the minority that would like to
write a report for the calendar
okay represented page so if both of you
could get me that report by like wednes
I mean I Wednesday before noon is my
deadline so any time before that would
be great thank you um and I'm going to
adjourn for lunch um and we will meet up
at 1:00 and at that time if we have time
I'm going to try to exact HB 444 today
okay have a great lunch
everyone
e
e e
all right it is 10:5 we're going to get
the housing committee back to order I'm
going to open the public hearing on HP
382 and call on um representative Joe
Sweeney the prime sponsor who I just
only met recently welcome all right
thank you very much chairman Alexander
and to the uh New Hampshire housing
committee I really appreciate that we
have a permanent housing committee uh
now to tackle the housing crisis in our
state uh I'm very proud to introduce
this legislation uh for the record my
name is representative Joe Sweeny from
Rockingham 25 um and I think I would
just uh could briefly describe this
legislation as the end of the spectrum
of parking reform uh we did significant
and great work in the last term uh when
this was just a special committee on uh
parking reform across the state to make
sure that we can encourage more multif
family development in the State uh and
it really does require a little bit when
we're reading through the legislation uh
a vision that we all have to have for
the State of New Hampshire uh it kind of
helps if you if you drive through a
commercial town so I represent the town
of Salem uh we have Route 28 that runs
up and down our town we've had a lot of
great commercial development over the
years that have made us a great town uh
and we have a lot of unused parking uh
and that parking is there not because
the people that were building the
developments wanted all that parking uh
but because because there are formulas
within local zoning codes and and
government formulas that have developed
over the years uh that have made sure
there is ample parking uh a lot of
people will refer to it as Black Friday
parking so that there's enough parking
for busy stretches of days for just one
day a year and it's to me it's a it's a
housing concern it's also just a
development concern because when when
you look at the actual physical space
that a parking spot takes up where it's
9 feet across and 20 feet uh down uh you
take just two parking spots and you have
the footprint for a studio or a
one-bedroom apartment um even even a
generous two-bedroom a small two-bedroom
apartment you could fit just on two
parking spaces so when we look at the
the leral space that we have and The
Limited space we have in the state for
development especially for new uh
redevelopments of already paved Lots in
the state without having to cut down
trees or to go into untouched uh Parcels
of open space
uh The best scenario would be to just
enable developers to examine their
current properties that they have and
allow them to build more housing more
and there not just housing they can
build more commercial operations on the
existing lots that have already been
paved onto the Earth uh at the end of
the day and and to anybody that's
watching this or to any of the committee
members this will not lead to zero
parking spots in New Hampshire after the
bill is signed there will still be
plenty of parking a developer is is
going to build as much parking as a
developer needs in order to Market their
development so whether that is one unit
uh one parking space per unit for their
development if that's two parking spaces
per unit if they have a restaurant and
they want to have 40 parking spaces for
the tables that should be up to the
developer uh in the ongoing
conversations we're having in the state
about permit reforms and regulations and
cutting red tape uh this the parking
formulas that each Town varies town by
town uh do add a lot of red tape and a
lot of unease to the development process
uh we have enabled uh under our zoning
code and under the laws of the State of
New Hampshire we've enabled
municipalities to adopt parking
regulations uh and this bill says you
know what we we tried the parking uh
experiment we have overregulation
the conversations to go forward uh with
the developers in mind to utilize some
of that parking space some of that real
estate for more productive uses uh and
then we could get into a whole other
category about how it will help local
taxpayers because those parking lots are
a drain on our tax base in uh throughout
municipalities and throughout the state
but that's kind of a 10,000 foot
overview over this legislation I'm happy
to answer any questions the committee
may have and I'm just glad to be here
thank you representative Sweeney are
there questions for representative
Sweeney
representative buo yeah I just have a
quick question um you know obviously as
time goes on um what people use for
transportation changes I mean you know
if we looked at something 150 years ago
I me people are using a horse and buggy
with the anticipated changes with
self-driving Cars ride shares things
like that in the future is there an
expectation that parking needs will be
less that's a phenomenal question
representative I I I I would say I agree
with you uh that that definitely the the
need for parking is will be less we're
also in a very fascinating time in human
history where starting in the post-war
era the pattern of development of sub
Suburban development and just the way we
built out sprawl and made it so that you
know every place had to have ample
parking for twice as many people uh the
econom is changing the way we we commun
the way we transport and the and the way
we interact with one another the economy
is constantly changing so I I just to
say I
agree representative Hicks thank you Mr
chairman um thank you for this
legislation I think it's interesting one
question I have and having seen this in
planning board for a decade and a half
what if a what if a business um does not
create enough parking and there is too
much demand what does the municipality
do about that what is the recourse in
municipality
I I would think that if a business were
to develop were to build out their their
retail or their their housing and they
didn't have the parking to support it
that business would not do
well because if people aren't able to to
go to the actual business if there's not
Transit options around if there's not uh
opportunities for people to get to that
Business Without parking their car I
think from a market standpoint that
business won't survive so I and and and
there there might be questions we face
as external
externalities from the municipal
standpoint but at the end of the day if
you if you're a business model that
relies on having enough parking and you
don't Supply that parking that's on you
as the business owner and as on the
developer and you'd either have to
partner with local businesses to work
out a shared parking agreement uh but I
would just leave that up to the market
to
decide representative howand um I just
have one question so 674 215 is impact
fees and so you're saying you don't want
me to ities to regulate parking would
you not want municipalities to charge
impact fees that potentially would go to
parking impact fees that would go to par
I don't the purpose of this legislation
is not to touch the impact fees so if
that's how you would read it that it
impacts the impact fees impacts the
impact say that 10 times fast um then I
I certainly might be worthy of an
amendment to make sure the impact fees
authorization is protected um but I I I
really just want to take away the
the regulation and the requirement that
there's a certain number of parking
spots determined by the municipality
that each type of business or housing
specifically housing is required to
have other questions representative
Sweeney seeing none thank you great
thank you all so much all right next up
I'll call on N
GRE thank you Mr chair n Grace for the
business and industry Association we are
the Statewide Chamber of Commerce and we
are in support of this
legislation um I think uh representative
Sweeny touched on a number of points
that I want to touch on so in the
interest of time I will not be
repetitive um but what I do want to
point out is uh under the legislation uh
that was created last year we now have a
very complex set of State uh rules
regarding parking um a a better option
for this uh would be to simplify it um
the current statutory scheme sets up a
lengthy uh basically regulatory process
that developers uh would have to go
through if they want to do something
other than what the minimum parking
requirements uh require currently um so
this would both simplify that process um
but also to go to uh I think a point
that was uh made by uh representative
Hicks over here a question represent
made by um representative Hicks is um
you know depending where you are in the
state and the pattern of development
that's going to that's going to dictate
kind of the natural um the natural
aptitude for creating uh additional
parking spaces unless I'm mistaken I
believe it's the case that conquer does
not have any parking requirements for
downtown um and yet there are a number
of flourishing businesses here there are
alternative parking options um whereas
if you know you're outside the city in a
more rural area you're going to need
parking on site for your business um but
that's something that's going to be
assessed uh by developers at the time
for on the commercial side and then on
the residential side same thing is uh
you know if you're building for a
population that's not likely to have as
many vehicles you know uh maybe an
elderly Community you're not going to
need as much parking as you would for a
community that's geared towards uh maybe
young professionals who are more likely
to be uh have a two Family household uh
have two cars and be commuting to work
so you know these things can be done at
the developer level they don't they
don't need uh local regulation to
accomplish it have to take any questions
the committee may have questions for Mr
Grace seeing none thank
you maybe we're just waking up lunch um
next up is Sarah bar Cohen
good afternoon Representatives my name
is Sarah Burke Cohen I represent the new
New Hampshire Municipal Association the
nhma um opposes House Bill 382 I'm sure
you're not surprised um so we have a
number of issues with it um we feel like
uh although we appreciate um development
and um understand the housing crisis in
New Hampshire We Believe that local
control is important for this issue of
parking um on-site parking currently the
way the statute is written is it allows
municipalities to to have control of
their local land to my local land use
and it allows them to determine in what
areas maybe on-site parking or as much
on-site parking may not be necessary I
think that um the testimony that was
just brought up um about development
relative to see housing or out of town I
know conquered is a little bit different
um downtown conquered you have a lot of
um ability for on-site uh off-site
parking um whereas uh there might be
some more ability for um less parking
restrictions out out of town or more
need for um parking restrictions there's
a lot of reasons to have uh on-site
parking um part of it is certainly
health and safety issues um if there is
a lot of if entities don't have on
inside parking where do people Park they
park in the street or they Park um in
public facilities so some of this can if
people are parking haphazardly let's
face it we've all seen those people
before um it can cause problems for uh
safety of people getting out of their
driveways maybe somebody lives near a a
place where somebody um people are
parking half Hazard it also can cause NE
more neighbor disputes where people are
uh jocking for spots um certainly we've
seen that in area neighborhoods not in
Hampshire necessarily but in Boston
where I went to school um there's snow
removal issues that can be caused by not
having a lot of on-site parking where
people are parking on the streets um the
community Aesthetics can be affected by
uh not having a lot of on-site parking
if people are going to park on the
streets um so at the end of the day the
people that know best about how to use
their land and how to determine what
needs on-site parking to as um as stated
by the statue right now and maybe what
needs less on-site parking is the local
uh the local town or municipality so
therefore uh New Hampshire Municipal
Association opposes the spill I'll take
questions
questions um so yeah my concern is over
the retaliatory nature of requiring
parking spaces
specifically say a local plan planning
board decides they don't want
manufactured housing in their town and
they say in their ordinance you know
what for every manufactured housing unit
we need five on-site parking spaces a
little ridiculous when you say I hear
what you're saying do you think that
maybe there should be some sort of guard
rails to reain in out of control towns
when they tried to zone out specific
building or development happening in
their Community certainly if
representative Alexander had uh language
that he would like to produce I'm sure
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
would like look at it and review it it's
a great
answer other
questions okay seeing none thank
you uh Matt
mushin alander just turn on your mic for
us thank you afternoon chairman
Alexander and members of the committee
uh my name is Matt Mushi and I live in
Claremont and I serve as the advocacy
and engagement director for a 603
forward a nonpartisan nonprofit
organization dedicated to educating
activating and empowering young people
in New Hampshire uh thrilled to be able
to testify in front of this standing
housing committee and uh today I'm here
to testify in support of House Bill 382
um there's a lot of evidence that
suggests removing costly parking
mandates and allowing developers and
Property Owners to decide for themselves
whether or not to build and how much to
build of parking will have a positive
impact on development and overall
affordability parking requirements uh
play an important role in housing
development in a few ways including the
added cost of that parking whether there
there is enough developable land to
support the parking mandates and the
parking development overall uh impact on
affordability for tenants most often
these parking requirements are minimums
set by either per uh bedroom or per unit
and these one size fits-all rules really
don't take into consideration whether or
not a building is on a bus line uh is
going to be home for seniors or home to
people who just don't have cars um in a
recent study allowing home builders to
create less parking created significant
increases in the number of homes that
could be built the study found that
allowing home builders to determine
where and how much parking to build
provid to result in an increase of 40 to
70% of homes uh being built as a result
of the removal of those arbitrary
parking mandates um parking requirements
also compete with the land as you've
heard and uh on average two parking
spots can be can take about the about
the same space as a one to two-bedroom
apartment um HB 382 takes an important
step towards addressing this issue by
allowing for just more flexibility in
these parking requirements by allowing
our policies with modern development
needs such as the increase in use of
public transportation car sharing
programs and things like bike friendly
infrastructure this bill not only
reduces the unnecessary cost but also
promotes more sustainable and Equitable
growth in our communities cities across
the country and uh here in New Hampshire
have removed parking mandates uh and it
is clear that parking is still being
built but it's just being built in a
thoughtful and responsive way uh
supporting HB 382 will make it easier
for developers to build housing and to
meet the needs of our communities
ensuring that more New Hampshire
residents can access safe affordable
homes and furthermore this reform would
help New Hampshire stay competitive and
attracting both businesses and residents
but also contri contribute to the
long-term Vitality of our state uh so we
ask you to please vote and support uh
House Bill 382 and I would take any
questions questions representative Hicks
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
testifying today do you think that this
um legislation is necessary at the state
level um for the reason um that chairman
Alexander spoke about and also uh in
contrast to what a previous speaker said
because many towns are using parking as
a way to prevent certain types of
housing in our state yeah I think the
short answer is yes we see it even with
things like accessory dwelling units
when towns want to uh perhaps uh
discourage the development of those
really restrictive parking requirements
being placed on that which just is a
barrier to that housing being built so
yes represent bullio um so let's just do
a thought experiment let's just assume
that the critics of this legislation are
correct and this will lead to a shortage
of parking in New Hampshire in your
opinion which is the greater societal
harm a New Hampshire that doesn't have
enough housing or a New Hampshire that
doesn't have enough
parking at New Hampshire where there's
not enough housing we are number one in
the increase of homelessness in the
state so we should be doing anything to
make sure people do not have to face
that other
questions seean thank you thank you take
care I have you
van welcome
back CH no place I'd rather be uh thank
you so much for letting me tell justify
I am no surprise in support of this bill
uh for all the reasons that people
already said but the one thing that I
would like to remind you of is that the
Institute of Traffic Engineers who
created all those lovely tables that
tell you how many parking places you
need for your swimming pool based on how
many gallons it has in it for a public
pool admitted about 10 years ago that
basically they made those numbers up so
a lot of this the rules around how much
parking do we need for what are based on
nothing and the other thing I'd remind
the committee of is that many many many
jurisdictions in the United States have
already eliminated their parking
requirements which does not as
previously noted eliminate parking seab
Brook New Hampshire is one of them by
the way and a lot of them are small
places that don't have a robust public
transportation the other thing that to
remind you of when you think about
parking and housing is that almost
onethird of houses nearly one-third of
households in the United States and in
New Hampshire are one person one one one
we don't need two parking places for
every housing unit and quite
frankly as people do move a little bit
away from Cars I'm not suggesting that
people in New Hampshire are going to
give up cars we all know we need a car
to get around
however lots of households are figuring
out that cars are expensive I've
forgotten now what the number is what it
costs annually to operate a car and
insure it and maintain it never mind
whether you've already paid for it or
not but it's an expensive it's an
expensive proposition and when we
require more parking for everything we
spread everything out further which
means that people have to have cars
because things are spread out farther
and then we have to have parking for the
cars and it's a death spiral let's not
um and what we're seeing in the planning
world is that uh households are
beginning to swap over to one
car and maybe an electric bicycle or one
car and not anything else because people
are working from home so I think that
the idea that we know how much parking
is necessary and that the amateur
planning boards of New Hampshire and
they are lovely people and they work
really hard no we're really bad at
figuring out how much parking is
necessary I think we should stop trying
to do that and particularly in the to
answer the question of what do we need
more of parking or housing it's not
parking and I'm happy to take questions
thank you miss van are there questions
super I'll be back next week I'm sure
see you
later um Grace
Marie good afternoon chairman Alexander
members of the committee my name is
Grace Murray and I'm testifying in
support of HB 382
um I work with New Hampshire youth
movement as the political director and
we're a movement of young people across
the state of New Hampshire that focus on
issues that youth care about and one of
the biggest issues that youth care about
right now is housing and more
specifically the lack of
it um I'll also be emailing the
committee with informational with an
infoi with uh the sources that I'll be
citing
today we all know that New Hampshire is
facing a housing shortage on top of
prices also being astronomical many
state and city governments are
considering or have already removed
parking mandates to allow Property
Owners to choose for themselves whether
to build parking or the amount to
build this policy change has been shown
to significantly increase the
feasibility of building more homes and
also reduce the cost of building those
homes by removing unnecessary
restrictions with a vacancy rate of 6%
in New Hampshire it's time for some
robust legislation to address this issue
that affects the thousands of gr uh
homeless gr estaters and also just
housing secure granted Staters and
anyone who just can't find
housing by removing parking uh mandatory
parking minimum Statewide we can address
problems like the lack of supply and
high C cost of housing while also
allowing Property Owners to have uh to
strategically determine how many parking
spaces should be built removing parking
minimums has already been proven to Be
an Effective tool across the country and
municipalities in our state um HB 382 is
solid bipartison legislation that will
positively imp impact residents across
the state I urge you all to pass this
Bill thank you any questions for Miss
Murray thank you very
much and the last person I have to
testify is William
hble welcome thank you Mr chairman um
this I'm from North Conway this is the
first time I get to uh testify in front
of Representative
page um I'm representing lur Bartlett
water Precinct North Conway water
Precinct and I'm a policy analyst for
Granite State Rural Water which U is
affiliated with national wh water I want
to I want to just
U give you a vision of what what uniique
things are going on in Mount Washington
Valley uh I'm very much in opposition to
house built 383 because of what I'm
about to
say um if you've ever read some of the
stuff about quantum mechanics recently U
entanglement means everything's
connected and when you try to plan
something at the local level you have to
take all of all the other things into
consideration so every Community every
municipality has the ability with a
vision of its people and the input of
its people to create a master plan for
the town land use land use Master
planning and at the same time
we all know we need
housing housing needs
density density needs
Wastewater the Wastewater Grant
requirements uh say that you have to
have an engineer Consulting engineer
hired by the municipality to study the
master plan of the water Wastewater for
water protection for for the delivery of
clean drinking water so that Master Plan
has to blend in with the master plan
vision of the town on the the land
use when you take away a tool in the
toolbox of planning at the local level
you pit one of those against the other
and I'll give you an example uh the
selectman just sent me a message to
relay to you if I if I might uh in
opposition to this bill um prior Speaker
of the House jeene Chandler is a
selectman there he signed it um the
chairman of the planning board in
Bartlett signed it um I got a gentleman
Richard plush from U uh Zoning Board of
adjustments in Bartlett for 30 years and
he sent me an email and I'll forward
those to you on online
um the Bartlett doesn't think that U the
Town of Bartlett and his people do not
think that uh what's good for Manchester
is good for Bartlet and that would apply
to every
municipality the real wisdom of of
municipalities at is at the local level
now if we have a a problem with parking
think about how you might enable more to
be flexible on that level don't take
away the rights of the people in the
toolbox to plan where parking should be
as it's compatible with the master
plan Mount Washington Valley is being
inundated with Humanity because it's one
of the small best small ski Towns now in
America and we're losing all our
families we're losing Workforce housing
uh people with money are coming in
buying up the housing a lot of New
Hampshire has face that sort of thing
that's part of what the housing crisis
is how do we create housing for families
for residents for full-time people so in
Bartlett they're uh looking towards
getting a in law a position where lore
Bartlet which is which is a sub Precinct
a subgovernment entity of the state uh
about to build a $20 million Wastewater
facility that's going to go into North
Conway water precincts treatment
facility and they're opposing for any
sewer to go up into Bartlet why they
don't want waste water to go by because
it means they now have growth imposed
upon them that they wouldn't have if
they didn't have
Wastewater and so it's an easy way to
stop population from coming in and stop
housing by denying Wastewater
that un that's an unintended
consequence all of that can be sorted
out locally and we all know how hard it
is to come together locally uh that in
itself is quite an
accomplishment um and we're about to
face that because the town of Conway
just took over Conway Village fire
District's water system so for the first
time the town of Conway will be in the
Water Business and we're trying to
expand the town of Conway's Wastewater
out into areas where the master plan
said housing should be
located so now now housing and planning
becomes a tool for how we get and this
is a test a 2third bond boat to build
that Wastewater so if we want housing we
really need to uh keep keep our planning
local and and now educate our our local
people all the citizens and all the
elected officials how to work together
and unentangled things but considering
the entanglement of everything
it's quite a quite a thing so please
don't uh don't take away the rights of
to to locate where people will park when
they build these housing take away the
rights of the planning to locate where
parking locks should be uh for
commercial especially when they're
considering the the parking runoff and
we're trying to protect the water so we
can get the people in the housing it's
all intertangled so I strongly oppose
anything you do here that would weaken
planning on the local level and thank
you very much for giving me this much
time Mr chairman not a problem any
questions we have a question if you
don't mind sir Miss HBO um
representative Gibbs thank you Mr chair
and thank you for coming this morning
this afternoon to testify um but I do
have a question uh and that is how would
eliminating Municipal parking
requirements interfere with Wastewater
process processing and the availability
of clean drinking
water well when you try to in a in the
vision of a master plan uh locate where
you want housing or where you want
business you have a res uh commercial
zones residential zones um you you take
into account through site plan review uh
how much parking that business is going
to need how much parking the
residential's going to need uh to not to
take that into consider it the local
level as part of where where the plan
master plan says that should be located
causes a dilemma because now it
intertwines with transportation and in
North Conway Mount Washington Valley if
you've ever been up there you it goes
from a population of 15,000 to 36,000
overnight on a Friday night uh you you
can't really get through there it's
backed up now they were going to build a
bypass but they didn't the state pulled
out because the bypass was going to be
built to go to Berlin and gorm but then
they found that the that wasn't a
problem the destination point was North
Conway they didn't go beyond so they
pulled out and didn't build the bypass
so now we got a mini bypass dumping onto
our side streets and into our
neighborhoods we we have quite a
transportation dilemma that has to be
sorted out with parking and parking is
an integral part of all of that
Transportation part
also go go ahead go ahead thank you uh
but wouldn't that um allow for as
representative uh as chairman Alexander
said earlier wouldn't couldn't those uh
parking requirements be used uh for
reasons that have actually nothing to do
with parking but rather to uh keep out
of the municipality certain types of
housing for for totally other
reasons no I think it would work in the
opposite fashion the real Challenge on
planning is to have people understand it
come together and realize where parking
should be as it intertwines in in
transportation and water and housing and
that that thoughtful planning uh it
takes an awful lot of citizen
participation understanding if you if
you take away the tool that allows them
to do that by saying parking you no
longer can control that centralized
approach down here in conquer isn't
going to work it isn't going to work for
Manchester or North Conway or or any
towns in the especially the rural parts
of New Hampshire so I think if if
Manchester is looking at u a problem
with parking we we ought to look at what
flexibil what more flexibility can we
give Manchester give them more tools uh
but don't take away the tools of all the
other municipalities that need to look
at their own plans individually and most
of the knowledge to accomplish that is
at the local level
thank you I hope I hope that answered
your question or at least gave you my
point of view of the answer to that
question all right other questions
seeing none thank you is there anyone
else here to testify on House Bill
382 seeing none I'm going to close that
public hearing um I was going to
get representative Reed was just here
and now I'm going to open up the public
hearing on HB 558 and call on um
representative Ellen Reid who is the
Prime
sponsor and uh representative you can
fill out a bin card after that'd be
great I will I will thank you Mr chair
and thank you honorable members um for
the record my name is still Ellen Reed
and I still represent Rockingham 10 new
market and
newfields as in many of your
towns I have quite a number of renters
who come to
me with oh my God my landlord whether a
new landlord that bought the property
without anybody knowing or the same
landlord my landlord has just raised the
rent 200%
250% it went from a th000 to 2,000 or,
1500 to 3,000 what do I
do and whenever these landlords pretty
much without exception are questioned
why did you your costs couldn't have
gone up that
much right the your pro we know how much
property tax you're paying we know how
much this and that you're paying and you
know you may have slapped a coat of
millennial gray on the walls but you
know you didn't do
substantive like you know renovation
that would actually mandate this kind of
rent increase what why are you raising
the rent this much and almost without
fail the answer is the same that's the
market
rate who is making this Market who's
making the market because this landlord
blames that one and that one blames this
one and they're all just going up
together and there is a pattern when you
see this happen and basically Bally any
industry and it usually correlates with
a practice an illegal practice a immoral
practice that we call price
fixing
so price fixing for anyone who's taken
econ 101 is
anathema the Enemy Number One really of
the free market capitalist system now it
may not surprise any of you I don't
identify as a free market capitalist
however I did take e 101 and and other
class and other courses in my in my
Master's Degree uh and you can't price
fix and have a free market capitalist
Society because it absolutely undercuts
the idea of competition what it means is
that one half of that supply and demand
equation has gotten together and
prevented competition by unilaterally
raising the price so that you don't have
options anymore as the consumer as the
demand side you don't get to make
choices based on who is doing better and
who's offering the better goods and
services at the better price it
absolutely takes away the invisible hand
concept of the free
market we can't monitor what's happening
unlike the insurance industry or the
energy industry or any of any number of
other Industries we don't have data we
don't have a centralized source of
reliable data for what rents are we have
you know
basically uh what people are reporting
but we don't have one centralized source
of actual hard
data so what this bill would do would be
to ask the register of deeds for each
County to create a um method which I
imagine most of them would create an
online portal because that would be a
very small amount of upfront labor
followed by not a lot of more labor
after that by which they intake
information from every landlord who's
renting a property in the county and
that landlord will supply and the onus
is on the landlord to supply yearly by
December 31st their rental amount the
location the bedrooms bathrooms the
amenities so that we have a a
centralized source of data that we can
then study the market because this is
the biggest crisis in the in the state
and we don't have the data that we
need I don't know how we we are
completely unserious about the housing
crisis if we don't even want the
information to study what the heck is
going
on
so um I understand that some of the push
back and there's a second part of the
bill that I'll get to I understand that
some of the push back um from the
majority maybe of the register of deeds
I have privately from two Register of
Deeds personal opinions that they are in
support of this
concept um but as a whole I understand
the push back as is the push back
anytime we do anything with any
department or municipality generally
these government entities that we kind
of oversee don't like to be told what to
do they don't like extra
work so I get it it happens on every
single Bill where we try to do anything
but this is a very minor amount of extra
work at most at most for the irre if you
set up an online portal there's The
Upfront cost and then you might maybe in
December hire a part-time short-term
extra help maybe but I honestly think
any regularities in the reporting
process probably could be
absorbed I'm sure you'll hear the
contrary but it's a small amount of
extra work but what we get out of it is
so valuable because now we get to see
okay you raised the rents because this
other landlord raised the rent because
it's now it's the market so who was the
person who started raising the rent and
did they have a reason to raise the rent
we can actually study this Market that
all the landlords are blaming for this
this ever increasing rental rates that
are pushing out all of our workers and I
know I've said this before and I know
I'm probably going to say it again in
this committee we are pushing out the
people that we need here the working age
Working Class People are leaving I had
multiple dozens of people in New Market
when we had a landlord buy and triple
the rent leave not just New Market where
they made our food and did all the s
they delivered our mail three of them
were postal workers they left the state
in 20 years we will not have enough
nurses working here to take care of all
the people in nursing homes this should
be a wakeup
call so the data we're getting from this
for the amount of work we're adding the
data is super vital super
important now in addition there is an
affidavit on this form that the landlord
would have to sign on the online portal
or whatever saying that they do not use
software to determine a rent now we can
talk about the wording I think the
intense is clear somebody emailed the
committee and said well what about
spreadsheets and like that's not the
spreadsheet has never told me what to do
I look at the data in a spreadsheet
however what that's referencing is a
very real problem an institution an
organization of business called real
page which has been under lawsuit from
the federal government for price fixing
because price fixing isn't just to
people to sellers to suppliers in the
supply demand privately having a
conversation it can be a de facto price
fix where you're using a a software an
algorithm to communicate between all of
us and that's exactly what real page has
been doing and well over 95% of the
large landlords use real
page so I understand that with real page
being sued there may be other
alternative systems that will operate
and function like real
page if this committee decides to amend
this out so we get rid of the data
collection and just say hey you can't
price fix through an algorithm that's
fine whatever whatever step in the right
direction uh that we take but I will say
that data collection is very important
if we um can see our way to to keeping
that in so some of the arguments you may
hear there's a um as with most
legislation that does not uh
uh create a a criminal offense there's a
60-day enactment so a 60 days after
being signed it goes into effect perhaps
some registers of Deeds are worried that
they wouldn't be able to implement this
in 60 days they don't have to it would
get signed in the summer and the first
deadline for landlord's reporting is
December 31st so they have six
months to get up a portal a website that
says here's the information we want um
another thing is they're worried that
they wouldn't be able to enforce these
landlords submitting this information
it's not their job like most of landlord
law we don't have like a real
enforcement
organization it's literally if you
happen to know a landlord or if your
landlord is breaking the law you file a
complaint the cops don't show up at the
landlord's door and arrest
him you just file a complaint and you
take it to court so the county
has really nothing to do with the
enforcement they are just collecting the
data and making it publicly available
for
everybody so anyway yeah uh price fixing
should be illegal it's anathema to our
system it's creating a housing crisis
and uh this is just data Gathering it's
a very small amount of work for a very
large payoff but even if you don't do
that we should definitely make it clear
that price fixing via algorithm is
illegal and that is my testimony I'm
happy to take questions well thank you
representative reader their
questions cool right seeing none thank
you uh Kathy
brwby thank
you good afternoon chairman Alexander
and um housing committee members my name
is Katherine Barby and I'm register of
deeds in straford county and I'm
president of the New Hampshire registry
of deeds
Association um on behalf of the New
Hampshire registry Deeds Association
I've submitted a letter in opposition to
House Bill 558 outlining several
concerns that the registry of deeds
Association has with the bill the
registry of deeds Association does not
agree that the landlord registry that is
proposed by House Bill 558 be housed and
AD administered by the registry of deeds
offices the purpose of House Bill 558 is
completely different and is not related
to the current duties functions and
responsibilities of the registers of
Deeds as set forth in New Hampshire RSA
478 what is proposed by this bill really
is data collection and it is
inconsistent with the grantor grantee
indexing and processing used by the New
Hampshire registry of deeds offices
which is required by Statute
essentially if this bill were passed as
written there would be established a
completely separate registry for
landlords within the registry of deeds
offices requiring additional technology
and Staffing to effectuate its goals and
I think that that was admitted by um
representative um Reed our vendor who
provides technology and services to over
300 registry of deeds offices throughout
the country does not know of one
registry that also houses a landlord
registry after researching landlord
Registries myself throughout the country
I've not found that I also have not
found one that's reg that is housed in
the registry of deeds offices further
the requirement set forth by House Bill
558 which was mentioned by um
representative Reed
it there is a concern you know for that
to be up and running even if it is six
months you know after there is a concern
of the registers regarding getting that
implemented I mean straford County alone
we have approximately 138,000 residents
about 38% % of them rent so those
numbers show that it's not an
insignificant undertaking to have that
set up in our opinion and to have it
done correctly um further the bill
proposes that landlords annually record
with the county registers thereby
requiring thousands of additional
recordings per year with no mention of
fees or if the individual counties
should absorb the additional costs
related to these recordings I'm actually
quite surprised Uris that there would be
this type of Bill that would
be sponsored without any type of
consideration about the costs associated
with you know with implementing it um
also I would like to mention that New
Hampshire RSA
541b currently requires landlords to
file a statement with regard um a
statement of agent for each property
that a landlord owns within the city of
or town where the um property is located
um the Deeds Association believes that
if the landlord registry were to go into
effect that it should follow New
Hampshire RSA 540 and be administered by
the individual towns or offices that
that would be the more appropriate place
and um you know and looking at these
across the country it seems like that
that is where the majority of landlord
Registries where they're in effect where
they are um held or or kept and um
I think even I think Rhode Island
actually has it in their Department of
Health so um thank you for your
consideration um it's if anyone has any
questions I'm happy to try to answer
them for you does anybody have any
questions thank you okay thank
you representative
Yuri thank you for the record uh my name
is uh you po of representing District
Mar Mark 10 hook and Dan Barton uh I'm
here in opposition to this bill uh I I
want to thank this committee for making
uh housing uh more affordable and as we
get more housing it will help with uh
pricing for housing but this bill is not
it it put some honorous uh uh tasks uh
on land owners and restrict uh how they
put pricing so uh please uh walk to
increase housing and it will help with
prices uh uh please uh uh iail this Bill
thank
you thank you does anybody have any
questions see none thank
you Matt Beacon
New Hampshire
Realtors good afternoon everyone I'm
Matt bacon I'm a realtor member here in
the state of New Hampshire for the New
Hampshire Association of Realtors as
well as a member of the public policy
committee and the commercial investment
board of realtors public policy
committees uh NH is opposed to House
Bill 558 lease terms are a private
contract between a landlord and tenant
intended as short-term agreements unlike
home sales which are long-term uh
contract this bill would likely hurt
quite a number of tenants uh the reason
we believe this is that publicizing
rents will allow an artificially
standardized pricing in to develop in an
area um for example landlords might come
to recognize that they're offering units
below the area rents which could drive
prices up um and this illustrates the
inaccuracy of the sponsor statement that
landlords are price fixing without this
since landlords can currently look up a
list of recently offered and rented
units uh and see what comparables exist
in the market today um the real driver
of Rental rent changes in this market
are construction costs and lack of
Supply the lack of supply has been in
existence since before the pandemic and
inflationary spikes and costs that we're
experiencing today so this is well
documented also by the New Hampshire
Housing Finance Authority in their
official studies that have been
published for years a public registry
will oversimplify rents by excluding
information that is important about
condition motivation and more that is
needed when landlords consider sending
rents as well this could also mislead
potential renters and landlords there
were about 177,000 residential sales in
New Hampshire last year it's a
manageable number of transactions to
register there are hundreds of thousands
of residential leases in New Hampshire
which change not just annually but often
monthly the cost to administer and
maintain such a list would be
significant as evidenced by the
testimony of the county regist herself
eventually Property Owners would be
asked to pick up the tab which would
only exacerbate our housing crisis and
be a disincentive to landlords to add
more units or to keep rents low the path
to lower rents is for the government to
allow more units to come online in our
New Hampshire towns and cities through
reforms in our zoning laws House Bill
558 is offered under the guise of
helping atrisk tenants but it will make
our affordability crisis worse thank you
thank you happy to answer any questions
are there any questions representative
hegner thank you so much chair um thank
you so much for coming to speak to us
and I'm just um trying to figure out I
know places like Conway um the municipal
level is already trying to do a landlord
um registry to track these type of
things to educate us more so we can get
to the bottom of this just any thoughts
on that uh I don't see a lot of need for
the town to do that to educate it um
some of the best quality research I've
seen on housing rental rates home sales
occupancy rates comes from the New
Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
which accesses direct landlord data they
pull people
um they use HUD data as well as
administering the subsidies that are
used in these communities so um I think
that that's something that is a very
limited pool of people trying to do some
research that is already being done by
someone with a lot more research
capability and I think we should if
anything focus on expanding what New
Hampshire housing is doing to understand
not just the the current market and
where it is but also to continue to try
to solve the
problem follow up yeah just a followup
uh sorry um so if landlords have this
like um registry where they can look at
comps shouldn't it be fair that renters
could probably do the same thing on what
landlords are doing so um I'm not aware
of anything that uh landlords can use to
look up rents that um most tenants can't
use as well um most commonly when I'm
looking up something to lease a unit
that I own I look look at what Zillow uh
Craigslist Facebook Marketplace have had
for recently advertised units I compare
where my unit looks like those recently
advertised units and that's how I set my
pricing to make sure that I can lease
out the unit um there's not any
advantage uh of looking way back in
history or of having something that
includes rents that were uh from people
that moved in 10 years ago which this
would then publicize and more than
likely have those landlords that have
those uh lower lease to raise them in
the
future any other questions seean thank
you thank you Christopher
Freeman all right uh good afternoon uh
Chris Freeman um I am the executive
manager of beltower property management
and I also sit with the madok resource
Alliance um today I am representing
myself and not the views of the manano
resource Alliance um I'm speaking here
today to urge uh the committee to vote
in expedient to legislate uh on the
basis that the proposal substantially
conflicts with the landlords uh
pre-existing compliance obligations
which would preempt the landlord from
complying with the proposal um uh in
ways that violate the consumer privacy
rights of tenants and which also Place
uh strong upwards pressures on rents uh
in conjunction with the landlord's fair
housing compliance practices um if I
have time I'll also get to the first fth
and potentially 14th Amendment
violations that are implied by the
language of the bill um but just to
start off um with the uh landlord's
obligation to comply with The Fair
Credit Reporting Act under federal law
under current law landlords fall under
the purview of ficra um at certain
points including during screenings uh
and also if they extend structured
credit to a tenant they potentially uh
qualify as a creditor so that would be
an example where a landlord has um
accepted a payment plan as an
alternative to a non-payment eviction
for somebody who is in a rears on their
rent um under the proposed law landlords
would become furnishers of financial
information um and that's on the basis
that the information that they would be
providing to a public reg registry is
highly likely to be used for
determinations of creditworthiness um we
would use that information that's
publicly available to uh provide a fraud
control check in rental applications so
we request uh information on rental ad
address history including the rate that
they have paid historically and if this
information were available we would be
cross-checking it to see if we relied to
on the application which means that it
is a um document and information source
that is used for establishing
creditworthiness um by being compelled
to submit data into this we become reg
uh regulated furnishers of financial
information which means that we would be
obligated to tightly control the
dissemination of any personally
identifying information and because this
information is being provided at the
unit level and it's very easy to find
out information about residential
addresses using public records including
websites like fast people search.com it
would be very easy for members of the
general public to identify with
specificity uh how much individuals were
paying in rent and that could lead uh
it's it's clearly a violation of the
tenants consumer privacy rights under
ficra but it could also lead to um
issues with stocking harassment targeted
uh uh targeted Financial scams uh ET
ET
um uh so that's it for ficra um under
the Fair Housing Act uh sophisticated
and professional landlords will
typically maintain a compliance
framework uh that is intended to not
only ensure that they do not actually
discriminate against prospective or
actual tenants but also to proactively
defend against the appearance that they
have discriminated against tenants and
the problems with having a public record
of all those rents is that it reveals
only the negotiated outcomes of the
leasing transaction and not the actual
details of that transaction and so there
are plenty of legitimate business
reasons why there could be natural
variations in rent you might have
somebody who is an inplace tenant who
has been there for years and you may as
a measure of loyalty have kept them
below inflationary adjustments we do
this fairly routinely um we might have a
longer term lease that we offer
favorable pricing we might have a
shorter term lease that we offer higher
pricing in order to offset our increased
administrative burdens and the problem
with a public rent registry is that none
of that is apparent to third parties who
might be reviewing it and um due to
sampling issues you could potentially
end up with a situation where somebody
who's receiving a favorable rental rate
belongs to one me one protected class
and somebody who's receiving an
unfavorable rate belongs to another one
and a great example of that would be
travel nurses which due to uh recent
Visa regul ations uh and initiatives by
the hospitals have been
disproportionately people of color those
rates appear higher in our rent data not
because of the membership in the
protected class but because they are
only signing a three-month lease
commitment and in order for us to
justify turning that unit over every
three months we need to charge a higher
rate to cover our
costs um and so I I think what would
happen if this law were passed is that
uh landlords defending against the
appearance of unequal treatment would
have a very strong incentive to raise
all rents to the highest defensible
market rate that's what I would be doing
um and and yeah I'll I'll stop there on
that one um in addition uh the language
about algorithms is unconstitutionally
vague and fails to provide landlords
with uh proper notice of their
obligations so it doesn't Define what an
algorithm is but according to Google uh
an algorithm is a process or set of
rules to be followed in calculations or
other problem solving operations um so
that could be something as simple as a
mathematical operation that could be as
simple as saying last month I rented a
1,000 foot apartment for $1,000 this
900t apartment should be
$900 uh it could also potentially
Encompass the calculation of voucher
payment standards set forth by housing
authorities which are determined on an
algorithmic basis that includes the
statistical analysis of rents in a given
market area uh with adjust ments made
for recent mover status so um the need
to adjust for that speaks to the fact
that many landlords do keep their rents
lower for established Tendencies so much
so that HUD when determining what a true
market rent is has to adjust for it um
you know barring this I'm not sure how I
would go about setting my rents I don't
know if I should consult tea leaves or
sacrifice a goat and look at the end
Trails um I'm reminded of a recent
headline in uh the satirical newspaper
the onion which read
landlord forced to raise rents due to
thinking of a bigger
number and I'm wondering if that is all
I would have available to me when it
comes to pricing my
rentals and that is all I have to say
thank you I was I thought that was a
great way to end okay any questions for
Mr
Freeman seeing none thank you for your
testimony um David Klein
my name is David Klein I'm a small
landlord with properties on the Sea
Coast
um start off with rent prices are high
because of supply and demand it's basic
economics we do not have sufficient
Supply this bill will not add one unit
of Supply to help reduce costs not even
one unit and in fact it's going to raise
taxes on the county level to support
putting together the registry and if you
notice it's also asking for layouts of
the apartments size and so forth all
that information is already collected
Now by local tax assessor office so
we're going to have two government
entities collecting the same data total
waste of taxpayer
money um and I'm going to cut some of my
comments because they were covered by
other one other people um one of the
things that I heard from the
representative the sponsor is about
price fixing there was no empirical data
presented Ed at all to you nothing other
than the program exists and I'll will
tell you it's a small landlord I didn't
even hear of it or know of it my method
of looking for what I'm going to rent my
apartments for is the same as the person
from the broker who's in before I look
up Zillow which is exactly available to
everybody we look up crawick again on
the internet and that's what we use and
part of my problem with the bill is that
last section 10 we shall not use any
algorithm or any software it's very
unconstitutionally vague it doesn't tell
us what the prohibited practice is a
very simple example is if I use
QuickBooks software look up how much my
taxes insurance and heat bills have gone
up in the last 12 months to make sure I
build them into any rent increases that
would be violating the statute and
that's a very standard common practice
how much of your costs gone up before
you make a rent increase so that this
bill is ridiculous in the way it's set
up it's uncon constitutional and I would
ask you to vote against it I thank you
thank you questions seeing none thank
you um representative cybert cert my
apologies that's okay actually you had
it right it's actually cyber I just I
quit correcting people on it it was a
lot easier um yeah I'm just coming
before you today in support of this
legislation it's very obvious that um
just beneath all of of it we need
numbers we need more data um and we need
some sort of data collection that's only
fair and we do owe it to the citizens of
New Hampshire who are consumers you know
and we tend to not have a lot of
Consumer Protections and that's truly
what this is um I just believe we really
need to just make sure nobody is going
out of the bounds and then there's not
like this domino effect um you know if
one person you know decides to go crazy
with their pricing or something like
that um we need to be able to keep um
our Workforce here in New Hampshire um
the big or small Workforce no matter how
much you make um and that's what I have
to say about that any questions thank
you questions for representative
Sebert um representative
Faxton one brief question you said we
don't have numbers are you familiar with
the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority yeah and are you familiar with
their annual rental analysis that they
do yeah so you know that every year the
New Hampshire Housing Finance Authority
generates a detailed report on the cost
of housing by County by unit number and
every other possible metric you could
have so isn't that good enough well I I
it'd be good to have more of a state
level um initiative of that and just
account by count not always just like a
yearly thing because within a year
prices can just jump and it's good to
actually look at it and be able to see
why
and
where more specifically go ahead well in
new so you want like a daily you want
like the Stock Market ticker on this I
would say every time an apartment gets
rented out to a new person yeah so you
would be able to follow that on
realtor.com or Zillow or any of those
places if you want to follow the market
but you you have a much you have you
ever looked at the nham Housing Finance
Authority report I should probably look
at it a little closer but um very
detailed and everything you've said
isn't available is there in detail well
I can't answer to your question so okay
you haven't seen it it seems like that's
not helping the situation okay any other
questions for
representative seeing none thank you for
your testimony representative
Howard thank you honorable Mr chair and
uh committee members thank you for
having me today my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the of straford and barington in
straford District 4 uh I'm in support of
this legislation because I think that
this is a good way that we can actually
track uh what types of uh rents are
being charged because this is landlord
specific the the representative faxon's
Point uh with the New Hampshire housing
Alliance it's not landlord specific
secondly I mean my family we we then the
real reason why I'm here today is
because uh we we're uh landlords we ran
out an Adu uh for about 11 $100 a month
uh and it's uh something where we would
be more than willing to submit this type
of data to a a a a program that would
track this I have no hesitation in that
it is about trying to create an
opportunity for people to understand
what the market is like here uh as well
as trying to create an ease in
Opportunity so that we not necessarily
uh we're not necessarily forcing people
out out of our market and forcing people
out of our state because they can't
afford it uh with that being said I'm
open to any questions thank you
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you thank
you last to testify is Nick
Norman thank you once again for the
opportunity to speak there's so much to
say on this one um I I would probably
only say a few things a lot of good
points have already been made by
speakers for me that are opposing the
bill I do have written testimony that
was emailed to this committee last night
and I've got an extra paper copy that I
could turn
in as well so there's just so many
points to cover um I don't see any
perceivable benefit by having this large
complex um data of rents because rents
are so individual and they portray is to
the the reasons that that rent was Set
uh like Chris Freeman said there's many
conditions in in why you set set a rent
you can't just arbitrarily look at two
bedroom two bedroom two bedroom and say
that it's comparable it's it's not
really quite comparing Apples to
Apples the New Hampshire Housing Finance
survey does give us a tremendous amount
of data this would just be a large
duplication the tax assessors do have
already on their records the information
on
um the amenities and the square footage
and size and so forth I should think it
would be a tremendous problem for
releasing tenants Privacy
Information um this so easily available
to get enough information from one
source and another to identify
personally identify a person and find
out you know where they live and their
rent and and the rest of that it would
be a big burden on the uh registry of
deeds it invokes the th000 a day
penalty which I think is ridiculous uh
in the email that I sent out by the way
there is an explanation of how that
works and how we come up to the ,000 a
day if you're unfamiliar with it you can
click on a link there and it'll explain
it definition of a landlord is way too
broad you could have a family member
renting to their relative their niece or
um close relative um let's say a a room
for two months and so now they have to
report that to this
registry uh the whole thing about U
algorithm is is fairly
absurd so there is I understand there's
a push back against companies that do
renov
Ren Revenue management uh real page is
one of them but not the only
one um the portrayal of that software is
is is not what it is those softwares
actually will look to minimize vacancy
so that it increases the profitability
of the apartment um
management and many times
that leads to suggestions of lowered
rent it's there's nothing in it that's
price fixing if you want to understand
about Revenue management I'm in contact
with one of the attorneys for a very
large for actually real page um but the
entire industry and we could arrange a a
zoom conference
or some meeting where they could explain
exactly what this this software
does most landlords don't use it most
landlords don't even know about it most
landlords in New Hampshire are small mom
and pop operations they do exactly what
Chris was just saying that's what we do
in our agency something comes
available we say what's the market
bearing now we look on Zillow we look on
craigslist we see what others and then
are offering and say well what's
different about that apartment than mine
and now if I say well gee that one has
the largest square footage or that one
looks looks to be in a nicer condition
or that one's in a little bit better
area and this one's different and I make
adjustments for that excuse me that's
using an
algorithm that's
illegal it's like I can't think to set a
rent or be in danger of using an
algorithm or if I look up a uh ad on a a
marketing platform oh excuse me that's
using
software if I use my calculator to
calculate the numbers that's using
software
really if I put numbers on a dart board
and throw a
dart oh excuse me that's using a process
as an algorithm it's just uh I think
sorry it's just
absurd um it will deinen
divize developers and we don't need to
do things that tie up developers cause
more headache and grief for property
owners and disincentivize people from
investing in more housing in New
Hampshire there there's so much more I
have to stop at some point but I've got
pages of of notes on here and I would be
happy to answer any questions well thank
you for your testimony or other
questions seeing none thank you I this
in um I think we received that via email
you did okay
okay all right so is there anyone else
here to testify on um HB 558
seeing none I'm going to close the
public hearing on that um and I will
open the public hearing on well is
represent forgan
here if you do you want me to introduce
it if you'd like to introduce it on his
behalf did you hear youy quickly have
you heard from him today has he asked
you
okay okay I'm gonna pause for a minute
let the clerk get
organized and then yes I'll have you do
that just fill out a pink card for
me okay so I want to open up the public
hearing on HB 628 pring landlords from
discriminating against perspective
tenants holding certain vouchers under
the housing Choice voucher program and I
would like to call on representative um
Howland who is a co-sponsor um to
introduce the bill for representative
Oregan
all right I'm not I'm Al Holland from
Durham I'm not Timothy Horgan I'll try
to do my best quickly to introduce it so
the bill really I think is aspirational
it's asking not to discriminate against
uh housing Cho Choice vouchers and in
the bill on the second page or the third
page of it he really lists two real
reasons that uh landlords could use to
say that they weren't discriminating
against the housing Choice vouchers the
first one's pretty obvious the rent is
more expensive than the voucher and
therefore the landlord could say you
don't have enough money to pay for it
and the second one is that the dwelling
unit doesn't comply with Hud's housing
standards and so therefore the voucher
really wouldn't work for the property
and I I think that's all I can do to
introduce it I I can try to answer any
questions if you really want me to
uh yeah feel free to ask questions um
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair uh and
representative Helen um doesn't the uh
discrimination against Housing Voucher
holders effectively discriminate against
families with
children uh it
could representative
taxton
so in in looking at at uh the two the
two bases
for uh not accepting housing and I'm
sympathetic because uh to the bill as a
as like a as on an aspirational level
I'm not sure now we're to the problem of
the devil is in the details you know so
as a housing provider as part of my
regular business I can honestly say I
I've never turned anyone down who had a
housing voucher for the most part
they're good tenants you go back to that
whole conversation we had this morning
about why would I throw out a good
tenant I
wouldn't um but I I but on the other
hand I I have a
concern primarily about a because I have
had that uh situation evolve in the last
six months with people who wanted
properties who were Section 8 and the or
whatever program and uh the uh entity
that provided the the the uh the housing
voucher said well the rent's too much
and the Tenant unfortunately in both of
the situations I have in mind said it's
okay I'll cover it out of my share and
the housing represent Faxon can we get
to the question oh so the question is
how with this bill can you reconcile
that uh issue of if I the the Housing
Authority which administers the voucher
cont denying housing or trying to force
landlords to lower their rent to what is
effectively below the current standards
because the rents in the market are
going up and they're looking at old
data I think the housing Choice vouches
are set every year actually so they're
relatively uh kept up but I mean I'm not
supposed to speak against this bill but
I'd say like the one uh problem that I
would have in uh the a section would be
like if a tenant came to you and and you
said the rent was $1,800 a month and the
voucher covered $1,800 a month and you
didn't rent to that that tenant
theoretically you could be opened up to
discrimination uh representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I don't know if
you remember but about a week ago I
think to the day we heard about um
another
bill saying that you couldn't uh cut off
or Force electronic payments and that it
could be an option but like money was
money and so my question is um is the
money coming to the landlord from a
voucher if you forgive the expression as
green as anyone
else's uh yeah I mean ideally uh the the
vouchers are set at a high enough level
that the L there's an incentive for the
landlord to rent and still make a profit
and I think that's why they adjust
yearly representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um having
worked at HUD uh for 29 years I just
want to say your correct representative
H Allen that the fair market rents are
adjusted annually representative Gibbs
that's not a question my apologies okay
if there are no other
questions representative Reed thank you
again Mr chair and thank you again for
taking my question If a landlord says
that even though I'm going to get the
rent that I'm demanding that part of it
will come through your voucher program
and so I'm going to say that you can't
rent this unit wouldn't that be
effectively discriminating against
lowincome
people I don't have a good question you
can answer that if you'd like I don't
have a good answer to that all right I'm
gonna let you off the hook okay thank
you for your testimony next up is Matt
bacon
thank you all again I'm Matt bacon
realtor member just turn your turn your
mic on for us thank you I'm a realtor
member and a an adviser at anagnos realy
and development I also serve on the
public policy committees for both the
state and Commercial investment board um
NH is opposed to House Bill 628 um the
reasons for this is that currently under
both state and federal law a landlord
can't discriminate against a potential
tenant due to a number of protected
categories their age sex gender identity
race religion color marital status
familial status physical or mental
disability disability or national origin
and the failure to rent to an individual
due to any of these reasons is simply a
demonstration of prejudice and it has no
place in New Hampshire as Realtors and
as human beings we should be opposed to
these but choosing not to rent to them
due to a voucher holder is materially
different from this it's incorrect to
treat landlord concerns about the
administrative cost of Voucher Program
as equivalent to these other forms of
discrimination participation in a
Housing Voucher Program adds a sometimes
complex regulatory process which a
property owner may not want to subject
to themselves as well as a physical
inspection and entering of the premises
uh it is reasonable to consider this as
a potential way of circumventing the um
fourth amendment protection to an
unreasonable search and seizure by
requiring a landlord to allow people to
enter their premises U without a warrant
because otherwise they would be
considered discriminating and in
violation of fair housing PR practices
under this bill a landlord would be
required to seek from a state or local
Housing Authority some guidance on
whether or not their property meets
Hud's quality um standards and an annual
inspection and recertification would
likely be required with all the
necessary paperwork even if it was only
an application and they didn't actually
have a renter in the
unit keep in mind the landlord will also
likely need to seek consent for any rent
increase from the Housing Authority
again and other admin ministrative
burden and um another approval process
for the unit that they are working with
while some landlords appreciate aspects
of the voucher programs such as the
regularity of the rent payments others
choose not to participate due to the
bureaucratic requirements of accepting
vouchers and that ability to choose to
participate or not is the strength of
the program I personally have used
vouchers um and I still accept them at
my properties I found the process to be
convenient at times inconvenient at
others um and it's not the basis for my
decision the answer to our housing
crisis is to build more housing not
punish landlords and this voucher
program has been successful because it
is voluntary um and these reasons are a
far cry from not renting to someone due
to their race gender or national origin
um I would just like to also um Echo uh
question that uh representative thexton
was pointing out um that the devil is in
the details and in this section two as
the bill is written um it names it as an
unlawful discriminatory practice and it
has um only two
acceptions um to the
um to the penalties for it and that's
the rent charge for the dwellings above
that which the Housing Authority which
administers the voucher can lawfully
approve and the rent charge for the
dwelling unit is the same as the
landlord charges in tenants for a
comparable unit in the same building or
Housing Development or the Housing
Authority determines that the dwelling
fails to meet the housing quality
standards prbly at by the United States
Department of Housing and urbit
Development the problem with this is
there's no exception in here for denying
the tenant for others filtering criteria
of credit of background for eviction
history of the way that they treated a
unit when they um call for a landlord
reference or for their criminal
background um so there's nothing
clarifying that further in here as well
so I'll take any
questions um representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question
um are you aware that when we prohibit
one form of discrimination it does not
prevent you from denying on other basis
as you just listed that literally
prohibiting one form of discrimination
does not actually prevent you from
denying someone on another basis
discrimination is very specific to that
form of
discrimination are you aware of that in
our law I I'm not seeing anything
clarifying this in here okay that's our
law I have a followup are you further
aware that uh when a landlord rents out
a unit that landlord basically does not
have any real right other than for
emergency repairs over the interior of
that unit and so to say that a landlord
is somehow being violated for their
search and seizure is it it's the tenant
the tenant search and seizure when a
tenant is occupying a unit are you aware
that the landlord doesn't have that
right because they've turned over that
right to the tenant by fact of that
lease actually I'm aware that your
question um
ignores the fact that none of this even
becomes a lease where they've given over
that right until they've signed the
lease so it's still their property of
which they are in possession until they
sign that lease and this would make it
unlawful for them to exercise that prior
to signing a
lease okay that doesn't make sense okay
thank you representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um I'm aware
that there can be issues of complicated
administrative requirements with renting
to Section 8 voucher holders but I
wanted to ask you about um one of the
protected um uh classes in the current
New Hampshire law against discrimination
and that is familial status as you read
it out and familiar status refers to the
presence of children in the household so
doesn't
um uh discrimination against voucher
holders effectively discrimin against
families with
children uh I don't believe it directly
does as a matter of fact the reason why
I think that is because one of the
voucher holders that I rented to um
obtained a voucher for himself and for a
domestic partner and there were no
children involved um and it's impossible
to um State what exactly is going to
qualify someone for a voucher um based
on fam familial status and familial
status as I understand it and
discrimination um under that does not
just apply to the age or to uh the blood
relation it's actually that you can't
use the lack of a blood relation um as
well as the age of the household members
representative Gibbs followup uh thank
you
um
uh isn't true that if you look up the
definition of familial status in the law
against discrimination you'll find that
it refers only to the presence of
children in the household not to whether
or not people are blood blood relations
or marital relations or whatever else
representative I'm really
confused at this line of questioning I
think he's answered it I'm I'm confused
at what you're trying to get at so if
you have a direct question I understand
I think he's answered your question if
you have a different one Mr Shar I don't
think he has yet
um if you look up the definition of
familial status what do what does the
law say uh I'm not sure if it does uh
only refer to age in this case and if it
does um I understand that um that
affects the ability or inability of a
landlord to make a decision on that
criteria as it should um but I don't
believe that that necessarily has any
Merit to it being tied to a voucher
program specifically since voucher
programs are available to people uh that
are single that are in a domestic
partnership or have children and have uh
and many more circumstances it's not
tied just to
families um one more yes that's
it um I realize that you can only speak
of what your knowledge is and I realize
that that may be limited but in fact
don't most of the VOR holders um aren't
most of them families with children I'm
entirely unaware of what those
statistics
are thank you any other questions seeing
none thank
you Vanessa
blae thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Vanessa Blaze and I
serve as a director of policy and
planning for the New Hampshire Council
on developmental disabilities and I'm
tasked by the council membership to read
this letter into record our council
members believe that house bill 628
would have a positive imp impact on
disabled people their families and those
who support them according to the most
recent UNH Institute on disability
compendium over 12% of New Hampshire
residents are currently living with a
disability it is more essential than
ever to continue to support policy that
increases inclusion and enhances the
lives of the states disabled and aging
residents the DD Council membership
believes strongly that it is important
to prohibit housing discrimination
against people with disabilities
in the Statewide Housing Voucher Program
operated by the New Hampshire Housing
Finance Authority it is estimated that
approximately
66% of assisted households are headed by
a person with
disabilities the voucher program allows
tenants to obtain housing and pay 30% of
their income as a portion of their rent
local housing authorities using Federal
HUD funds pay the remainder of the
contracted rent the demand for vouchers
is so high that applicants are waiting
up to seven years to get one in addition
to the long wait times to receive a
voucher many people lose their voucher
opportunity because countless landlords
simply refuse to accept them or they
can't find a landlord who will accept
them within 90 to 120 days required this
is especially difficult when disabled
people rely on certain housing
accommodations the CDC reports that 0.15
% of housing in the US is wheelchair
accessible yet one in four people in the
United States identify as having some
type of Mobility
challenge HB 628 would make it unlawful
to refuse to accept housing Choice
voucher holders as tenants solely be
because they are receiving this
financial support landlords can still
screen tenants and apply other criteria
for not selecting tenants for example if
the rent for the apartment is high or if
the it is not approved by the HUD
minimum quality
standards these are only a couple of
examples landlords should not be allowed
to deny tency because they hold a
housing Choice voucher the DD Council
supports HB 628 in an effort to create
more opportunities for people with
disabilities to find stable appropriate
and affordable community-based
housing our Council by law is comprised
of 60% of people with developmental
disabilities and or parents or guardians
of people with developmental
disabilities these members are
volunteers advocating for disability
Justice by identifying the barriers to
Leading inclusive and integrated lives
of choice many Disability Advocates have
engaged with and want to continue to
work with the state's legislators
including on the special committee on
housing an HB 1168 committee to study
the effects that the housing crisis has
had on people with
disabilities it is policies like this
that could be one of the many tools that
we can use to combat this crisis we
thank you for your
consideration thank you for your
testimony questions representative Reed
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question as context for this question
I'm currently dealing um helping a group
of residents in my town legally um with
a landlord of theirs who has openly said
and his employees have openly said that
they would like uh more able-bodied and
younger people um both of which are um
protected classes so the question is is
can you foresee the fact that landlords
can discriminate on the basis of
vouchers can you foresee the idea that
landlords would use that as an excuse to
discriminate against protected classes
which would be illegal for them to
discriminate against so if there's a lot
of people for example with disabilities
who get V cures and the landlord doesn't
want someone with disabilities either
developmental or physical disabilities
that they could say because it would be
illegal for them to say I'm not going to
accept you on the basis of your
disability but perfectly legal for them
to say you have a voucher I'm not going
to take it can you foresee that being
used in that way yes I
can representative Gibbs thank you Mr
chair and thank you for coming in to
testify this
afternoon um where there or not the use
of discrimination uh against voucher
holders is a pretext for something else
as representative
redescribed um given the fact that one
of the groups protected um under the
current New Hampshire law against
discrimination is people with
disabilities and given the fact that so
many voucher holders uh are or include
in their families a person with
disabilities doesn't discrimination
against voucher holders effectively
discriminate against people with
disabilities we believe that it does yes
thank
you other questions seeing none thank
you thank you Nick
Norman thank you once again for another
opportunity to speak before the housing
committee uh last night I did send out
through email uh the test testimony that
I have here so you have that in
electronic form there is one printed
copy here if you want me to turn it in I
can uh there's certainly no way that in
any reasonable amount of time I could go
over all of the reasons why this should
be um not allowed we certainly oppose
the bill the primary problem here is
that the the Section 8
hcv program is is quite onerous in its
Administration and added
costs um that and it's just a large
government contract I think it's
unreasonable to think that it's okay
that the government can force an
individual private citizen into signing
a government contract that they have no
say over
then there
are large amounts of extra cost
associated with taking a section 81
it we can get into those if you
like but it can be fairly
expensive I'm pausing because there's
just so much I'm not sure what to say um
the issue here is a shortage of housing
not and the owner nature of this Section
8 program
a way better solution would be to create
a loss mitigation fund the state could
create a loss mitigation fund other
states have done this to help reimburse
the costs that are um incurred when a
housing provider takes on a hcv
tenant if that's something you want to
consider I I would be very happy to work
with you and our team would be as well
there was a bill last season that was
talking to that
effect let's see what
else there's no allowance in this bill
by the way for Resident owner occupied
Pro providers like there's no mention of
restricted non-restricted so every
single residential housing provider
would be bound by by the provisions
here section I'm sorry not Section 8 but
HUD is is the biggest problem with this
because
HUD writes rules and regulations that by
virtue of having a Section 8 lease which
has the hap
contract a housing provider would be
bound by those changes in rules and
regulations that again they have no to
say over one of them for instance is the
cares act um was which was in place
during covid had a provision ision that
if you were evicting for
non-payment the uh eviction notice would
have to be extended from the Hampshire 7
days to 30 days an extra
203 days of lost rent isn't a big
expense I I would encourage you to look
through this I I think it was nine pages
or so of of restrictions and uh
reasons why the program itself is the
problem now if if you wanted to have a
loss mitigation fund to help reimburse
those costs that would be that would be
workable that would actually incentivize
housing providers to accept the program
that's what we need to do is incentivize
housing providers to accept using the
program not not Ram it down their
throats I don't know if you know this
but under RRP rules which has to do with
renovating uh properties F before 1978
and properly handling lead paint the
restrictions for uh that that program
has two sides EPA side and HUD side if
you have a section 81 it you're bound by
the Huds side of the rule which has many
many more expenses and costs the uh the
expenses and cost just you know they
keep they keep going so I I'm going to
have to stop I think because I'm not
covering probably even 10% of what's in
here against why housing providers
should not be forced into a government
contract that's expensive and it will
only increase the cost which then get
translated onto higher rents and we just
don't need higher rents in our Market
I'd be very happy so very happy to take
questions okay um thank you for your
testimony represent Reed thank you Mr
chair thank you Mr Norman for taking my
question are you aware of and can you
accurately Define the term rent seeking
Behavior because when you not once but
twice suggest a government program to
pay uh landlords to cover costs related
to their business in addition to the
existing government program which pays
the rents for some people that's the
term that comes to mind so maybe you can
accurately Define that term what's the
term the term is rent seeking behavior
and since I'm only allowed to ask
questions I would encourage the entire
committee to look up that term
I don't I don't know that term rent
seeking Behavior I know that the section
H HUD program forces many many
additional costs and burdens in
administrations if you look at leasing a
residential Market lease you have this
many conditions and procedures to go
through if you look at renting Section 8
it's probably four times the
process representative Gibbs thank you
Mr shair and thank you for coming again
to testify to the
committee uh you mentioned the need to
protect owner occupied buildings doesn't
the New Hampshire law against
discrimination already contain
Provisions exempting small owner
occupied
buildings so in the RSA 540 there are
definitions of restricted and
non-restricted maybe that is what you're
referring to follow up um isn't the New
Hampshire law against discrimination not
RSA 540 but RSA 3
354a that one I don't know but what I
see written in this bill is the
definition of landlord would include all
landlords that rent out
Apartments it doesn't carve out an
exception for owner occupi or what we
would normally call restricted owners
isn't this bill an amendment to RSA
354a
NOP that that
well doesn't it start out saying amend
RSA 354 A10 354
810 it does indeed line
one okay there's a place in here that
defines the landlord I'd have to look
through it again
so perhaps this is in the wrong area of
the rsas but thank you representative
gives for poting that out representative
buo can I can I just make like a point
of order um maybe just directing on on
page two line 22 where it's section 22
um where it says rental of a housing
accommodation in a building which
contains housing of not more than four
families and depending of each other if
owner resides in one of the housing
accommodations so I think that's what
everyone was trying to find but I do
have a question go ahead ask your
question thank you Mr chairman
um so my my question is on these two if
this legislation were to pass on these
two proposed exemptions where there's
one if the rent is higher than what the
voucher amount is for or if the H if the
dwelling fails to meet housing quality
standards in order to not take a voucher
if you had a housing provider that did
not want to go through the burden of
taking one of these vouchers doesn't
this legislation create a perverse
incentive to either raise rents to be
more than the voucher or if you have a
unit that does not meet housing quality
standards do not improve the quality
standards so you're just to clarify your
question are you asking if this bill
were to pass yes would it incentivize
incen landlords to in fact it would
incentivize a price War it would
incentivize the housing provider to
price their rent above the the number
that the program
accepts and then the program would come
come back a little bit later saying
let's review what Market rents are
here's the market rent okay now we
approve this number then the housing
provider was say okay well now I need to
raise the rent higher so that I'm not in
the program or yes uh in it would be a
little bit harder to imagine someone
would do it but yeah I think it would
incentivize someone to leave the
property condition in a way that that
meets code but leaves it in a way that
wouldn't be accepted by Section 8 and
thereby
not providing better quality
housing representative Reed thank you Mr
chair thank you again so just to clarify
what you just said to not renovate so
that it's up to that standard but still
meets code so you're saying that there
is still a bare minimum code to which
everyone has to adhere right so it
wouldn't be like they would be in
shambles am I hearing you correctly well
naturally Section 8 requires things that
are Beyond
normal thank you any other questions
seeing none thank
you Kristen Evans
thank you chairman and member of and
members of the committee uh thank you
for the opportunity to testify in suppor
of House Bill 628 for the record my name
is Kristen Evans and I'm the director of
policy for AEL New Hampshire and AEL is
a disability Justice organization and we
are nonpartisan nonprofit could you just
pull your microphone a little closer
we're having trouble hearing you better
y okay we're a nonprofit organization
that fights for the civil and human
rights of children and adults with
disabilities uh housing Choice Val VES
are a critical tool for ensuring
individuals with disabilities that they
can access stable and affordable housing
despite the programs intent individuals
who rely on these
vouchers face significant barriers often
being rejected outright by landlords
based solely on their source of income
the demand for affordable housing in New
Hampshire is substantial according to
the New Hampshire Housing Finance
Authority approximately
35,44 residents live in subsidized
housing including those who use housing
Choice vouchers however the need far
exceeds availability in 2021 the state
issued
1,581 vouchers but nearly 300 expired
before being used largely due to
difficulty of finding landlords willing
to accept them additionally local
housing authorities report extensive
weight lists for housing assistance for
example the Keen Housing Authority
currently has 853 applicants on its wait
list these figures underscore the
immense challenges voucher holders face
in Access accessing stable housing in
the state discrimination against voucher
holders is widespread perpetuating
housing instability and inequality
according to a 2022 study by the urban
Institute landlords routinely reject
tenants with vouchers citing stigma and
misconceptions about program
requirements such practices unfairly
Target vulnerable prop vulnerable
populations and amplify New Hampshire's
affordable housing
crisis for people with disabilities this
issue is notably severe over 40% of
voucher holders Nationwide are people
with disabilities when landlords refuse
to accept vouchers individuals with
disabilities are left with no viable
Alternatives increasing their risk of
homelessness housing is a human right
and denying individuals access to
housing based on their source of income
perpetuate cycles of poverty and
inequality allowing this practice to
continue harms the most V vulnerable
members of our communities reducing
housing instability through fair housing
Pro policies like this one also have
economic benefits including Better
Health outcomes increased Workforce
participation and reduced Reliance on
costly Emergency Services House Bill 628
is an important step towards ensuring
fairness in New Hampshire's housing
market and Abel would be um happy to
work with the legislature to streamline
the voucher Pro process with uh for
landlords thank you for your time thank
you for your testimony
questions seeing none thank you thank
you last up um testifies David
kle turn your mic on for us please I
have rental units in the SE Coast Area I
do currently have four voucher holders
as tenants and I've had them for years
um one of the concerns that I have is
that one of the differences between
someone who has a voucher and someone
who does not is being able to screen
those tenants one of the worst things I
had to do as a landlord was go into my
parking lot and pick up hypodermic
syringes that were left by people who
were shooting up drugs because a tenant
was selling drugs we couldn't prove it
but there was happening those are
extremely dangerous to pick up you don't
know what what was on them what people
used and you don't know what diseases
are there and I had to pick them up
because I couldn't leave them because
potentially children could pick them up
and play with them and none of us want
to see a child injured on that grounds
so it becomes critical to me that I have
the ability to screen tenants one of the
problems with a voucher holders or let
me back up excuse me things that we use
to screen tenants whether or not they
have credit they have a landlord
reference employment reference and
possibly criminal history part of the
problem with the voucher housers is by
nature they lower income or they
wouldn't be able to get the voucher they
don't have credit it's not their fault
it just happens landlord references some
of them do some of them don't again if
someone's been on not been without
housing for a period of time they won't
have a current landlord reference
employment reference again it's a hit or
miss it might be part-time employment
one two of my Section 8 tenants now do
have part-time employment and we were
able to get them and a criminal it's Hit
or Miss what you're going to be able to
get if we just say wait a minute we
don't have that credit reference we
don't have a landlord reference it may
bring it up to enough of a percentage
that there's this Theory called
disparate uh
discrimination and that we cannot
protect ourselves from at all there are
instances where HUD or U Human Rights
Commission has used this Theory saying
well it's causing you not to be able to
take 30 or 40% of these people and
therefore it's a discrimination and you
shouldn't be allowed to do it well that
takes away all my tools to determine
whether or not this is a person who's
going to fit in or this is going to be a
person who's going to be a real problem
for me and it was raised by one of the
other speakers too so that that's
important to us and that something be
dealt with and addressed in this bill or
you determine not to pass the Bill
another issue I have is there's no limit
to the number or the percentage of a
building that I have to rent out two
people on vouchers it has been shown
that they do better if there's a mix
between people working people have of
different walks of life in the buildings
unfortunately if I gets out building a
has five Apartments I make it five
Venture voucher holders and I want to
say no to some of them I don't want to
have that many voucher holders in one
spot because I've had it happen once and
it it became problematic I don't want to
go into details because it's not fail of
the tenants so I'm am asking you to
think through this bill look at either
reforming it or not passing it thank you
thank you any questions representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question when you say that
removing or forcing you to accept
vouchers as a form of payment takes away
your
tools um to I I can't remember your
words I think you said figure out who
fits in and who might be a problem and
the specific comment you were
referencing was when we were saying that
this could be a tool for discriminating
against discriminating against protected
classes I'm just going to read those
classes and I would like you to tell me
which of these classes would indicate to
UA problem or someone who wasn't fit
represent read that's out of line that's
literally what he said I'm going to ask
you to
suspend thank you any other
questions thank you thank you Mr
chairman
all right is there anyone else here to
testify on HB 628 seeing none I'm going
to close the public hearing at 2:57 and
we're opening up the last public hearing
on
6:23 um and I want to recognize the
prime sponsor representative alisander
Murray
welcome thank you Mr chair and honorable
members of the committee for the record
I am representative Al Murray
representing Hillsboro 20 which is Ward
9 in
Manchester um the bill before you today
attempts to accomplish one very simple
thing to prevent corporations from
outbidding families who are trying to
purchase a
home I'll start by sharing my personal
experience with this problem a few years
ago my husband and I were told by our
landlord that he would be renovating our
apartment and that we needed to move out
back when this was happening in 2021 and
still to this day rents and Manchester
are the same or more than the average
mortgage so we decided to take the leap
and look for a home in the city that we
had always lived in together and we
nearly ended up houseless because of
that decision over the next two months
we viewed a number of homes even
venturing outside of Manchester which is
where we wanted to stay until the last
offer we made every single offer we made
we were outbid on not by other young
families but by corporations these
mostly out ofate groups would come in
often without even looking at the
property and put forward offers that
were irresistible to the owners almost
always paying in cash the most
devastating home we lost out on the
corporation overbid by
$150,000 and then proceeded to reach out
to my husband and I and ask if we would
like to rent the property from them this
is not a unique story and this is not
only a New Hampshire problem over the
last decade the number of investors
purchasing homes has increased from 10
to 15% each year except for from 2020 to
2021 which according to a study by red
fin saw an increase of over 80% leading
the industry backlash is the National
rental home Council the primary lobbying
Organization for companies that rent out
single family houses the group in 2024
spent
$360,000 lobbying Federal lawmakers on
efforts to rign in single family rental
companies and other similar matters
according to Federal disclosures which
is the largest annual lobbying
expenditure the group has ever
recorded when looking at the Wall Street
companies buying up homes you have a
small list of corporations that have
shaped this growing Trend one of the
first companies to make waves in this
market is Blackstone founded in 1985
Blackstone or Blackstone Group is an
alternative investment firm based out of
New York blackstone's total capital of
2021 set at 880 billion over a third of
which came from its real estate
department other large companies in the
American Home Market are JP Morgan Asset
Management Goldman Sachs mind management
and American homes for rent
these companies have bought and rented
out tens of thousands of single family
homes for the past few years American
homes for rent for example owns over
60,000 units operating in over 22 states
with the largest concentration being in
Atlanta
Georgia this trend accelerated during
the covid-19 pandemic when low interest
rates and Rising real estate prices
spurred investors to expand their
portfolios by 2022 investors accounted
for nearly 30% of sales of single family
homes up from an average of 16 % just 3
years earlier in some cities
institutional investors account for a
far higher share of single family
homes according to a 22 20 2022 report
by Matt life hedge funds market share of
the 7.6 million single family rental
homes in the US is projected to balloon
over the next decade from 5% in 2022 to
over 40% by
2030 as in my own experience because
investors are paying in cash they can
often easily beat out firsttime home
buyers researchers in Atlanta estimated
that the institutional investors robbed
potential homeowners of $4 billion in
equity by weakening home ownership
between 2007 and
2016 and on top of this once they buy
Homes single family rental companies
often prove to be bad landlords because
they are corporations that are often out
of state a 20 uh 2022 study by federal
lawmakers found that the five major
rental companies hiked their fees by 40%
over three-year period and saw their
tenants fall behind and rent in
California the state's largest corporate
landlord Invitation Homes was forced to
pay $2 million in sanctions after the
State Attorney General found it was
charging tenants illegally High rents
research has also documented that
corporate landlords file for more
evictions than small-time landlords
which can permanently harm tenants
ability to find housing in the
future um and I wanted to share that
this legislation is not new unique a
similar bill was introduced to this body
last session and Democrats and the US
Senate and the house have sponsored
similar legislation on the national
level a Republicans bill on the Ohio
State Legislature aims to drive out
institutional owners through heavy
taxation while lawmakers in Nebraska
Iowa New York Minnesota and North
Carolina are among those States um also
proposing similar
laws uh Republican Governor Greg Abbott
actually addressed this recently stating
that the corporate large- scale buying
of residential homes seems to be
distorting the market and making it
harder for the average Texan to purchase
a home this must be added to the
legislative agenda to protect Texas
families um so the difference I made
majorly in the legislation last time and
this time around was adding a 90-day
caveat so that a business or Corporation
could purchase a home once it's been on
the market for 90 days and the idea of
that is to give everyday Grant estaters
the first dibs and a chance at buying
these houses before corporations come in
and make offers that the landlord simply
or the owner simply cannot refuse views
um and yeah with that I'll take any
questions representive Reed thank you Mr
chair thank you so much for your
testimony and for taking my question you
mentioned um Blackstone which is our
nation's largest landlord not at all
unique many companies have followed suit
are you aware of a memo put out by
Blackstone that claimed that their goal
was to make this nation a quote nation
of
renters I have not heard that but I'm
not
surprised other questions seeing none oh
I'm Excuse me representative
Aaron how is this bill going to be
enforced because most of the time when a
real estate transaction comes to the
attention of government it's at the
closing and that would be way too far
ahead uh in the
process um I believe this bill I mean I
think unfortunately would probably be
addressed on the later end of the
process but I believe it gives the power
to the attorney general to enforce this
but um I can look more thoroughly at the
language I haven't looked at this since
drafting um are you are you all set yeah
I just would want to know how would it
come to the attention of the Attorney
General because that would be again
after the
closing yeah I think it would be in the
process but I'll double check and um get
back to you so so my question is is
regarding the the penalty um
line 25 it says the court shall if
they're find found in violation the
court shall declare the land as cheated
which I that's a big word for me I don't
know what that necessarily means to the
municipality or unincorporated place so
the the town or the municipality is now
taking ownership of the
property and
then they're responsible for upkeep and
control of the property
oh I'm looking at the wrong Bill what
line are youing I'm looking on on page
two line
25 the court shall declare shall declare
the land as cheed to the
municipality and or unincorporated
portion of the state the county which is
located when the es is decreed the clerk
of the court shall notify the governing
body the select Board of municipality
County that the title and real estate is
vested in that subdivision of the state
and authorize the subdivision of the
state
so to sell the property yeah so you're
talking
about towns being in the the property
sale business now I mean aren't they all
ready um the other thing I would be open
to um you know not to ask the committee
to do work on my behalf but I'd be happy
to make any amendments to this bill if
um you know there are amendments that
could be made to make it more palatable
to members I do think this is an issue
is that you know crosses party lines
I've heard from a lot of my constituents
about the issues they've um experienced
similar to mine with um buying housing
before corporations buy it up you know I
thought maybe lowering it from 90 to 30
days could be a good compromise but yeah
happy to work with Y all thank you
representative
Dumont how would this affect residents
of the state that would wish to purchase
real property under an LLC a trust or
even a corporation just to protect their
own interest not necessarily a company
but one that uses those tools to you
just pull the the mic a little closer
one that uses those tools to protect
themselves there are a couple exceptions
noted in here or like grandfathered in
Clauses but in general they would fall
under the same um they would also not be
able to purchase property single family
housing specifically under an LLC
whether it's you know one person that's
running the corporation or 100
yeah okay other questions seeing none
thank you represent
thank you representative
wheeler chair members of the housing
committee here in the house uh it's
congratulations to you all on being
appointed to this very important new
committee as all of us here you know
this is one of the more important issues
that the legislature faces so it's
always good when the legislature does
its job and makes a committee around
that issue so we can actually study it
I'm here today not to say that HB 623 is
a perfect piece of law or piece of
legislation uh but to say that
consolidation destroys economies and
what we're seeing happening with
Blackstone and black rock and State
Street and Vanguard where these Wall
Street firms not for one political arm
or the other or you know one just
because they like power and wealth and
you get a lot of power and wealth when
you own $23 trillion worth of the
economy and everything else you know I
hear a lot about housing from my
constituents the issue of Housing and
then I hear from some people in my party
and other parties well we should get rid
of zoning we should do this we should do
that there's a lot of issues around
housing but you know to me I see the
biggest issue with housing is that these
major corporations are
artificially manufacturing the market
and uh Rising prices by buying up these
homes in a way that keeps us from having
and participating in the market in a
real way you know as representative
Murray Illustrated
when representative Murray tried to buy
a house the corporation B came in and
bought it before them and then there's a
there's plenty of stories about people
who've tried to buy a house and then the
corporation comes in and buys it before
them you know so $23 trillion in assets
that's how much these big Wall Street
firms have in their economy everything
else I think is a bit of a joke it
really doesn't matter what your politics
are on this issue uh the world is being
bought up by people that want to buy the
world and and as they said in their you
know conferences and things like that
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
that's that's the world that they want
for us so you know to me the American
dream should be the American reality I
want to own a home I want to have a
piece of land I want to protect my
family on that land I want to make sure
that the economy works that the market
is open for all people it's transparent
and honest to me if there's these
corporations buying up LLC people say
Blackstone but it's really also these
fake LLC corporations not what your
question was referring to but I look at
you because you had brought up the llc's
where people they look at oh who bought
my house and it was this ghost LLC that
if you trace it back and you have to go
through 20 different shell companies it
ends up at Black Rock State Street
Vanguard all three of these same
companies and they've got a million
different shell companies all across the
world all across New Hampshire that are
buying up these homes and in different
ways and then it's able to say oh well
that was that LLC that was this LLC well
you know follow the money where does
that go and it goes right back to these
firms so can we address this issue in a
silver bullet kind of way with the New
Hampshire legislature and its power
maybe not but I think that we can begin
to address the issue by opening up maybe
a potential subcommittee on this issue
or a study commiss committee but just uh
intaking the information that we're
hearing across the state about the fact
that these corporations are buying up
these homes and maybe potentially
figuring out some way to make HB 623
work for us and our people so that as I
said in the beginning the American dream
can be the American reality and all of
us at one point or another in our lives
can own a home and own land and and own
and be happy and so we're not a nation
of renters so thank you very much Mr
chairman and again congratulations to
your all appointment to this committee
and look forward to seeing the work that
comes out of here thank you for your
testimony questions for represent
wheeler represent bullo yes thank you
and I I very much sympathize with you
know the story and the frustration that
happened that brought this legislation
forward I just really question um you
know really thinking this through about
you know just how this mechanism would
even begin to work putting aside the
Constitutional concerns but when you say
non-natural person does that include a
nonprofit my testimony was around the
issue itself I think as I said in my
testimony a subcommittee or a study
committee on this issue so we can figure
out how it works for the State of New
Hampshire is much better than uh coming
forward to this committee then uh with a
stick in hand and saying this is how
that stick's going to hurt I think
coming with a carrot and maybe studying
the issue and bringing together all the
different stakeholders and and conver
ation and talking about the issue is a
much better way to go about it than
debating the minutia of what the
drafting agents have have brought
forward us
today I'm gonna have a study committee
of all the people all the Reps that
testified in favor of this bill and on
it put on Mr chair on have at it tap me
in tap me in representative
Dumont thank you chair how often do you
see these large corporations doing what
you what you are saying buying up uh
large amounts of single family property
in the state of New Hampshire versus
residents of the state or possibly
residents from another state moving in I
don't think we have specific data on
what these corporations have done in the
state of New Hampshire but there is data
across the country and across the world
as to how much these corporations have
bought in and I think you could probably
average that data out uh in New
Hampshire I I don't have that data off
the top of my head but what I would say
is that over the course of these last
especially since um legislation was
passed five years ago by the federal
Congress to make this a little easier
that this has been happening I mean this
has been happening for a long time but
it's accelerated a lot over the course
of the last five years and I'd be happy
to send any information about that
nationally yeah thank
you representative Reed thank you I'm so
glad you quoted the line You'll own
nothing and you'll be happy I was
thinking that the entire time um so you
touched on the idea that there's been
reticence around issues like this in
terms of solutions to the housing crisis
that a lot of the attention has been
refocused on zoning um and and and
specifically on supply and demand yeah
as if that's the only cause to the
housing crisis and my question is to you
since our demand our our supply of
housing is not going up at the rate it
should but isn't is not decreasing right
the housing the houses are not burning
down um has the population of New
Hampshire increased so significantly in
The Last 5 Years that it's demanded a
triple or quadruple value that we've
seen has our population increased that
much no absolutely not I mean you know
everyone in my town oh I bought my house
for $100,000 and then the house down the
street just sold for
$500,000 I can't believe it and they get
very worried and scared so no
representative read our population as
far as I understand has has been quite
stagnant over the last eight years
representative taxton uh just to clarify
that question the population of New
Hampshire has increased by about 30% in
the last four years well I'm happy to
stand corrected you know the numbers
better than I great great um any other
questions for our
representative right thank you
representative wheeler representative
Sebert
again everyone my name is Christine
cybert um last time I was oh yeah and I
represent Hillsboro district 21 um and
last time I was here I told you guys a
story that was um pretty much pretty
relevant to all of this where I knew
this was about like maybe a year or so
ago it was when or maybe it was closer
to like two years ago 22 it was that
summer when all the homes were going on
the market and then being bought up um
and houses were being bought up from
right under people and I knew two
different couples one was my hairdresser
another one actually rented um you know
a one of the a duplex in the house
across the street from me and they were
looking to buy as well and both of them
it turns out talking to them at separate
times were actually going to the same
like few house showings that were
happening at the time that summer um
before houses were being totally bought
up um and they right when they would get
to the house o Open House the house
would be gone like somebody walked in
that morning with $100,000 suit in the
suitcase you know and then they can't
resist selling it you know me and my
husband moved here um back in 2012 when
he got a job here and we moved here from
Georgia so we moved up here we rented at
first over in the hookset area and and
when we found out his job was going to
work out um we had originally gotten
like a year lease and we started looking
for homes we were able to have time to
look for a home like any one would think
any normal couple can do that a lot of
y'all might have had the opportunity to
do at some point in your life we were
able to go house hunting say what we
liked what we didn't like have options
and then afterwards have time to go have
a beer and discuss you know what we saw
and if we wanted that um and then we
outbid seven other buyers for our home
but the original listing was like 239 or
something and we bought it for like 249
because I just was like let's just bid a
little bit over and get it um so anyways
now it's worth more than double that and
it's really not technically um but it's
worth more than double of that and I'm
not hearing the stories where people
have those same opportunities now with
the way things are going so we talk a
lot in the legislature about personal
property and we talk about having
personal property rights and all that
stuff and we all know that owning land
is power and it does mean it's something
of your own but if there's no land left
to bought be bought what are we going to
do are we really America are we really
the state of New Hampshire and Live Free
or
Die so that's what I have to say thank
you thank you representative questions
representative Reed thank you again
thank you representative um
would you be surprised if I told you
that according to the New Hampshire
fiscal policy Institute that since 2020
the the year to end all years um New
Hampshire's population has grown by
1.8% and the fastest growing County
Carol County was 4.7% would you be
surprised that information and do you
think that even 4.7% increase in
population would justify without the
interference of these businesses that
are trying to drive up the market would
only 4.7% or 1.8% Justify the triple and
quadrupling of values no I also think
that it's very telling about this
happening Nationwide and coinciding with
a lot of what has been discussed here
today I feel like that's not a
coincidence thank you other questions
seean thank you
representative um Grace Murray I don't
think she's here okay that's no not a
problem Nick Norman
thank you uh once again for an
opportunity to speak for the housing
committee uh on this one my testimony
will be much shorter than on on others
the the basic problem here is the the
way the bill is crafted it's just
unconstitutional and it does refer to
all legal entities so the title is
misleading it's not corporations that
are targeted by this
um it would certainly Squatch the
creation of Workforce housing which
would be a shame in our Market it'll
push developers away from investing in
New Hampshire we need to focus on
creating more housing not implementing
laws that reduce the construction of
housing let's talk about uh
unconstitutionality to have a property a
cheet back to the governing body County
or state or however it's written would
be a uh taking without just compensation
and a cheet does mean that the property
is given back to
uh uh in this case the
government um corporations and legal
entities for I presumably uh I don't
know 200 years supposedly have been
afforded constitutional protections that
entities Is Not A New Concept at all
entities are protected by the
Constitution and can transact
business the bill refers to non-natural
person that would mean all forms of
legal entities would be excluded
corporations trusts General Partnerships
limited Partnerships
llc's any form of entity including uh
nonprofit
entity certainly it would disincentivize
developers from building housing which
has all these restrictions they could
just build
Condominiums which would not have these
restrictions and that's just going to be
more expensive than creating Workforce
housing when you are looking at the cost
of developing housing it takes a lot of
money we've this no news right
everybody's saying it just doesn't
pencil out it takes lot of Revenue to
pull together enough resources to create
a development or to create housing and
so you need to have legal entities that
can pull together multiple people's
monies that they can come in and create
a development of new
housing so um I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you Mr Norman
representative Reed thank you again Mr
chair and thank you again Mr Norman um I
believe you said that the process I mean
you you raised a number of concerns and
I don't know whether we want to say all
nonprofits or are all non uh natural
entities or just corporations or what
have you um and I've heard the word
unconstitutional quite a few times and I
haven't heard any article or Amendment
cited with that so specifically you said
one of the things you said was
unconstitutional um and I would love to
hear what you're basing it on is the
idea of this cheating back to the town
so I'm curious why you think that's
unconstitutional when in fact don't
towns take ownership of properties for
example when there's a tax lean and the
owner hasn't paid their taxes on the
property and then the town goes through
a process takes over that property and
then sells the property to get their tax
money back is that also
unconstitutional so there's in eminent
domain the property the owner would have
to be compensated have just compens
compens ation I don't know if this bill
actually gives just
compensation and i' have to study that a
little bit more okay
I follow up are you aware that imminent
domain is an entirely distinct and
separate process from either leans or S
cheating those are different things so
you asked
about
unconstitutionality so in the realm of
constitutionality it would be
unconstitutional for a government body
to take someone's property without just
compensation emminent domain is an
example of where just compensation is
given the other thing that would make
this unconstitutional is that
corporations have been afforded the
abilities to transact
business this would take away their
ability to transact business
okay other questions seeing none thank
you Mr Norman thank you Matt
bacon good afternoon everyone again I'm
Matt bacon realtor uh and I'm here
speaking on behalf of the New Hampshire
Association of Realtors public policy
committee uh and the commercial
investment board of realtors public
policy committee
um NH would urge you to vote in
expedient to legislate on House Bill 623
uh first the bill prohibits non-natural
people from purchasing single family
residents until the property has been on
the market for 90 days um families and
individuals frequently purchase homes
using liabil limited liability companies
Estates um trusts many different types
of uh ownership that um come through
their families um and often um this ban
actually artificially
uh inflates pricing for them in the long
run they may do this for estate planning
privacy reasons protect themselves from
liability uh for the tax benefits
associated with it uh to operate an
inhome business where they finally are
getting to have a dream home uh for
their work um and in today's market
prohibiting someone from purchasing a
single family home for 90 days is
basically a ban on ownership of it the
average time for a single family home to
sell in New Hampshire is 28 days uh
likewise prohibiting an LLC Corporation
from buying a multif family residence
for 90 days and then allowing that
Corporation to only own that property
for 2 years would be one of the most
devastating things this legislature
could do to the availability and
affordability of rental units it is also
misleading to title this bill um text as
uh prohibition on the purchase of single
family homes given that the text of the
bill specifically says or multif family
following that and does not isolate that
down to restricted multif family
property or otherwise qualify that
language in any way again the details of
the bill would basically ban
corporations from owning multif family
residences and require only individuals
to own such properties without liability
protection without tax benefit and
without the structure that most of our
commercial real estate is built on in
the
state virtually all multifamilies are
currently owned and developed by some
type of Corporation many of these
properties are worth millions of dollars
and under this bill could only be
purchased and held by an individual not
an LLC or other cor corporate
Arrangement during the first 90 days
eliminating that incentive for a
developer to build or operate a multif
family will have the exact opposite
impact on the availability and
affordability of housing it will
additionally prevent most operators from
ever acquiring or getting pricing that
will allow them to make the construction
cost in today's rising cost and
inflationary Market
possible finally the National
Association of Realtors conducted a
report on institutional buyers of homes
and found that New Hampshire was 49th in
the percentage of such buyers only
Vermont had a smaller percentage again
again the so-called institutional
investors were almost exclusively
llc's not any of these larger
institutional investors large
institutional investors seek
disadvantaged neighborhoods where
properties are relatively inexpensive or
land is inexpensive places like Arizona
Texas Georgia Alabama
Etc they buy these they fix them up and
rent them or sell them at higher rates
or build them where construction cost
and infrastructure costs are lower New
Hampshire's High home and rental costs
and land costs as well as infrastructure
expansion costs make this prohibitive
and it means there are very few
opportunities for one of these
institutional investors to find a deal
and make it work I'd ask the bill
sponsor how many homes in New Hampshire
been purchased by Blackstone Blackstone
is the nation's largest landlord and
according to John Burns real estate
Consulting in a published report in
August 2024 Blackstone owns only
.6% of single family homes in the entire
us while all institutions collectively
only own one half of a percent no one
has testified as to how many homes in
New Hampshire have been included in this
number in fact most institution
investors are looking at the areas that
I spoke of before and that investor
ownership has actually decreased by 8%
from 7 years ago according to Census
Data under Supply is truly the cause we
are a nationwide shortfall of
approximately 5 million housing units
over the last 10 years according to that
same US Census Data while completing
fewer homes than before the great
financial crisis this is greatly
inflated cost and our US Census Data
shows demand for approximately 16,
900,000 homes in the last decade while
delivering just under 12 million a 71%
delivery on Supply if that was our food
or gas supply it would similarly Spike
pricing due to the imbalance of supply
and demand and create an inflationary
environment just like we've seen in our
housing
market interestingly the half a percent
of homes owned by institutions
Nationwide is insignificant at a
national level compared to to a 29%
shortfall in New Hampshire it's a
substantially lower percentage and we
have not yet heard a single data point
showing how many homes have been
allegedly purchased by Blackstone or
another institution in New Hampshire and
created any pressure so I would ask the
committee to please vote itl on House
Bill 623 thank you for your testimony
any questions representative
Reed thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question you're with the
realtors association yes okay thank you
um followup follow up Mr chair go ahead
I was just
clarifying because we've heard testimony
around the idea that corporations um and
other investment firms what have you are
aggressively going into the market and
spending over uh Market or making offers
over market price would wouldn't
Realtors stand to game financially for
corporations being in that market and
buying
property um I'm not sure that I'm
qualified to answer that question except
that to say it's actually decreasing the
transaction volume for realtors um in uh
2017 approximately 177,000 homes were
transacted in the state of New Hampshire
in 2024 it was a little over 12,000
leading to a lower transition of uh
total sales volume um not helping the
cause again under Supply uh would Aid of
course in your case of uh your question
here
um realtor transaction volume um but
more importantly to our citizens it
would increase the affordable housing
stock and this bill uh does not in any
way address what I believe the question
you asked were getting at okay thank you
for your
testimony and um last up to testify is
Chris
Freeman and Chris I know you handed in
pink card for 628 we already passed that
public hearing I might have handed you
mixed up the numbers but yeah 623 we
have that yeah agre um I'll keep this
pretty short that's a pretty tough act
to follow lots of uh very interesting
data points in that um so one of the
things that I'm not hearing mentioned in
any of the conversations that have
happened so far um is the impact to
sellers uh when they're able to command
higher prices because they have an
investor buyer um one of the things uh
that was really kind of struck me when I
first uh began getting into personal
finance and Investments was was in in
looking to set my own goals and targets
I looked at what what is the median uh
retirement savings for an actually
retired person like what's the the
number that you should be shooting for
and this number is probably about 5
years old now but uh at the time the the
median retirement savings were about
$167,000 which is not enough to retire
on and in digging into uh where that
that value was sitting it turned out
that uh almost all of that was people's
equity in their primary residences they
didn't actually have any retirement
savings and so for people who are
approaching retirement who have not
adequately prepared for retirement uh
their ability to sell their home in
downsize uh is a a key component of
their financial solvency in their old
age uh and so I I'm would be concerned
about any proposal that would seek to uh
prevent sellers especially elderly
Sellers from being able to get whatever
the market determines their home is
worth um in addition I think we've
already addressed the fact that you know
Black Rock ownership is um is relatively
small and sure there's going to be some
anecdotes on um you know somebody losing
out on a deal to an investor um but
uh I I've heard several people in their
testimonies and their questions ask well
what has the population done in New
Hampshire has it gone up has it doubled
has it gone up by 30% what's what's
ultimately driving the prices and I have
I haven't heard anybody mention the fact
that during the covid pandemic the
Federal Reserve dumped nearly $8
trillion doll worth of new money supply
onto the global economy and I don't see
any acknowledgement of the fact that the
US dollar is fundamentally a commodity
and that the value of all other
Commodities is denoted in relative terms
so when we have a 40% increase in the
money supply we should anticipate that
the prices of all other Commodities will
increase by at least Le that much if not
more due to issues with the elasticity
or in elasticity as the case may be and
real estate of the supply and I think we
need to acknowledge that there is
nothing no idea that anybody in this
room can come up with has any bearing on
what's going to happen to the supply of
the US dollar now or in the future the
only thing that this body can do is
clear the way for the creation of new
money supply and if we focus on any
other solution we're going to be missing
the mark that's all I have to say thank
you any questions representative Hicks
thank you Mr chairman I should have
asked this for somebody else but I just
waited would you consider a non-natural
a trust to be a non-natural person when
I read the bill for the first time I had
that question and I was curious um I was
thinking of specifically there's a
restaurant that we like to go to where
the owners have a disabled child and I
know that they were interested in
putting the property into trust to
benefit their disabled child in the
future I did have the question about
what whether that would compromise their
ability to do so follow up Mr chair um
yeah to follow up on that so if a family
had a their single family home in a
trust to avoid probate typically is why
they might do that right um should they
you know pass away or
whatever would they not be able to
purchase a single another single family
home
because they had a trust that trust
could not so they would have to purchase
it as a as a couple as a single person
and then reestablish a trust do you have
any idea uh I'm I'm not an attorney but
my belief is that if it was a revocable
trust they might be able to move the
asset back out and purchase something in
their old own name but then they would
ultimately be going through because the
the bill as written has a grandfathering
clause any new entity that was formed to
try to accomplish the same estate
planning purposes uh would then be
considered a non-natural person at that
time ones that were formed before might
be ex but I think it could complicate
people's planning going forward and
actually Mr chair if I could make one
additional Point um I also think that
this bill um significantly jeopardizes
new housing new development of
affordable housing uh so one of the
areas that uh I'm looking to break into
is um is litec development so low-income
housing tax credit development and uh
those projects uh tend to be relatively
low yield and they are very long-term uh
time commitments so you're going to go
and and purchase your property and
execute as one of these non-natural
people you're not going to buy and build
you know an 80 unit apartment complex as
you know Chris Freeman dude from Keane
it's going to be you
know Riverside Park Apartments or
something like that so I think you would
see a pretty uh significant chilling
effect on investment even in affordable
housing If This Were to
pass representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in um this afternoon to
testify I have a question about your
sorry about your discussion of the money
supply how does the level of the money
supply relate to the need of New
Hampshire residents for
housing so all prices in a market
economy are going to be impacted by the
amount of currency and circulation
relative to other Commodities so when
you add new new money into circulation
all prices rise that's a a fundamental
principle of Economics it's the the laws
of Economics which supersede the laws of
the legis
um the other thing that tends to happen
with uh money supply is um there's
there's what we refer to in finance as
the time value of money which represents
the opportunity for money to earn to to
generate earnings to generate yield and
um so there's a tendency when you add
new money uh to circulation that the
people who benefit the most are the
people who receive the money first and
when you are dumping new money into
circulation that's Banks and major
financial institutions get paid before
anybody else
does all set okay any other questions
thank you Mr Freeman for your
testimony all right anybody else here to
testify on HB 623 seeing none I'm going
to close the public hearing at 3:38 um
and I'm going to I believe
representative Paige wants to caucus
briefly yeah so let's have the
Republicans
um okay all right and then we're going
to caucus in this room briefly so if I T
can turn this turn off the stream um
we're going to re reconvene around
3:55 and if the public could clear the
room at the
earliest
e
e e
Brey okay so I'm going to welcome back
the committee on housing um open up an
executive session on HB 444 move out to
pass I'm sorry you opened up the ex I
move out to pass um I'm not calling on
you I'm not recognizing you recognizing
I opened up the executive session I'm
recognizing representative Daxton for a
motion we'll see if that's allowed
you're not recognized representative
representative
Daxton uh this is with regards to HP 444
I move itl is there a second to that yes
second representative Aaron seconds it
motion is to itl um representative
taxton would you like to speak to that
motion uh
444 I I think that the bill I think that
the public has other remedies at
and I think that there are other
opportunities and remedies for the
consumer and the public to purchase
property I think that it is an over
complication of the real estate transfer
process to require 45 days written
notice to the tenants in the building
and it is an unfair un
confiscation of property rights from the
owners of the
property okay anybody else wish to speak
on this representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair um I do have an
amendment uh to uh a proposed amendment
to HB 444 and therefore I would like to
move OTP so that we can discuss the
amendment um representative Gibbs if the
itl motion fails you are welcome to
offer the o TP motion and offer your
Amendment but right now the motion is
itl representative Hicks Mr chairman
with the same thing apply um if I wanted
to recommend a study committee or to
retain the
bill well speak you can speak to
anything as a member of the committee
sure but you can't make a motion for a
study committee or anything else until
the itl motion is dispensed of so can I
speak to the itl go ahead uh the reason
I'd like to retain this is I think we've
seen success with this with manufactured
um homes and I think there's a merit to
this that shouldn't just be discounted
outright by the itl so I think retaining
this or study committee or something
like that would uh would help us flesh
this up more thank
you other members of the committee
represent bolo I just wanted to you know
really point out in in the testimony
really highlight how detrimental any
amount of delay would be to 1031
exchanges and that is something that a
lot of people in the real estate
industry indry uh used so I really think
that there's some serious unended
consequences to this the other thing I
would point out is you know regarding um
you know manufactured housing Parks
which are very very different but you
know we have not really seen a whole lot
of development of those ever since that
you know law was passed so um for those
reasons I would uh support itl
representative
Reed so maybe you didn't hear um and
certainly Community Loan Fund can talk
about this uh it's been wildly
successful uh and all of the issues that
were raised that Were Somehow different
between manufactured housing parks and
um multif family housing
structures those are the same issues
that are faced by the manufactured
housing so when one that was raised was
repairs yes they actually roll that into
I know this cuz I'm helping right now a
community and manufactured housing in
Danville go Co-op so yes they have to
roll into it all of the repairs um
shared costs that's something that
manufactured housing Parks also deal
with one was uh brought up about
um structures that were like rented out
and owned by the community at large
that's also handled in manufactured
housing Parks so like if you were buying
a multif family house with that the
first floor was a business that would be
rented out by the community so all of
these issues that were raised actually
are already being dealt with with by
manufacturer housing parks and the idea
that that has not been successful since
the law passed in 1988 is absolutely not
true over 200 of these have gone Co-op
and they are doing much better than the
parks that have not both in terms of
more affordable lot rents and better
quality representative Dumont and then
representative
Gibbs for me the largest difference
between the manufactured home homes and
the multif family units say the
manufactured homes nine times that you
just speak up a little bit I think I
apologize for me the manufactured homes
the main difference is is that normally
those homeowners own the trailer or the
manufactured home that they are living
within where multi multif family units
they do not so for them to get an
opportunity in the Manufactured Homes
parks to purchase out that Park when it
goes for sale makes more sense than it
would be for a multif family home so for
that reason I would support
itl representative Gibbs thank you uh I
think the last speaker and also the
speaker before um representative Reed um
both um made part of the explanation for
my proposed amendment and that is that
one of the main objections dur to this
bill during the public hearing was that
there's substantial difference between
the manufactured housing Park and multif
family housing and therefore the
amendment totally takes out of the uh
proposed bill um any reference two
procedures for um manufactured housing
Parks because they are different from
multif family housing and the other um
objection was that 60 days is too long
and might interfere with closings so for
that reason uh the amendment proposed is
reducing 60 days to 45
days further
discussion representative Reed I just
don't understand why like can
and not to single you out representative
D but you you did just bring this up why
would there be a discrimination against
people if they can get the financing and
that financing is on the lending
institution the the seller gets the
money so why would there be a
discrimination based on people who have
not yet owned a home like that doesn't
make any sense why would be like well
those people bought something and so
they they should have the right but
these other people haven't that that
doesn't make any sense at all to me and
I'm just wondering if you can explain
why we wouldn't be actively trying to
get more people to own homes
representative sure and I appreciate the
question uh it's not an act of
discrimination those groups already have
the ability to come together and
purchase that multif family dwelling
just like any other group would be this
makes it mandatory that you offer that
to them the same way that you would a
manufactured home it it's not the same
process there's big differences between
the two there's no discrimination by by
saying saying that we're going to itl
this if a if 10 or 15 or 20 or 40 people
want to come together in a multif family
unit and group together their funds and
make an offer they have every right to
do
that
representative so technically even
before
1988 residents of a manufactured housing
community had the ability to come
together but the problem is that people
who are buying just like today buying
multif family people who were buying
those Parks could buy without the
residents they would close without the
residents ever even knowing that the the
property was for sale so the only thing
this is doing is doing what ended up
allowing those people the opportunity
which is to just give them a
notification of sale and especially with
the amendment that would only be 45 days
hardly anything closes that fast anyway
and it doesn't even reference the RSA
around manufactured housing Parks but
the the point is is that like that
you're saying they already have the
chance but def yes just like
manufactured housing residents had the
chance before 1988 but de facto they
didn't because they didn't know it was
for sale and the same is true now of
multif family residents they don't know
it's for sale and all of a sudden they
have a new
owner I mean anything's for sale it just
depends how much you offer it I guess
like there's nothing to respond to that
there's nothing stopping tenants from or
people that live in one big unit of
getting together similar to the way you
form a union I mean coming together
organizing and saying you know what we
want to purchase this property
anything's for sale it doesn't matter
how much it like it is what it is you
know like they'll sell it depending on
what the price
is did you want to go representative
deont go ahead yeah thank you and I do
really appreciate the discussion in my
mind just the great or the bigger
difference there is the fact that the
manufactured home law that you speak of
that came in 1988 was strictly because
that majority of those people owned the
property sitting on that land which is
why it was a greater importance to let
them know what was going to happen so
that way that land wasn't just sold out
from underneath them there is a big
difference to that versus multif family
units who there a leas holder stake
versus an actual ownership interest in
those other Parks but thank you
representative
Gibbs thank
you um just to clarify if the amendment
is approved there would be no reference
in the statute to the procedures for
manufactured housing parks that would be
totally eliminated and what the bill
what the remaining bill would do
would be to provide notice to tenants
that the building is going to be sold
and it would address the problem that
we've heard about that there are tenants
who only find out that the building they
live in has been settled when they get a
notice from the new owner that their
rent is being substantially increased so
all this is saying is that In fairness
they should have an opportunity to know
before it
happens represent
Reed thank you you um to the extent
someone
owns a what we used to call trailer
manufactured house um and that gives
them more buyin I mean ultimately
housing insecure is housing insecure
homeless is homeless um and the ability
and this is an issue that the people I'm
helping in Danville are facing which is
if somebody buys it and they jack up the
lot rent to something unaffordable now
they're stuck owning something that they
can't pay the lot rent on and they can't
sell because nobody else wants to pay
the lot rent so you end up being
homeless and homeless is homeless and as
ingratiated as I am that the chair has
joined the ranks of my comrades talking
about unions um I
think finally I finally did it um uh I
think that you can say yes technically
they had anything's for sale and maybe
that's the way a person with billions of
dollars laying around thinks but these
people don't normally think that and we
know from real world information right
we know that
pre-1988 manufactured housing Park
communities did not have the
wherewithall to come together and make
those offers once they had that chance
to do that that's when they started
coming together and doing that and doing
it successfully so we know that that
notification resulted in actual people
buying homes um or buying the land under
their home so while it's technically
true Mr chair I would say that
notification has proven in the real
world world to be vital to the actual
realizing of that okay represent Volo so
so um if I could just ask to followup
question that so is really what is
needed really what you're driving at is
the
notification versus the opportunity to
purchase because to me what really
really I really don't like about this is
it basically freezes the sale process
for 45 days and spends a lot of time on
that if there was just a simple notice
that would be different but this is
effectively every time you're trying to
sell the property you have to say okay
wait let's wait 45 or actually 60 days
because we're looking at the unamended
version you know just sit and and and
wait go ahead uh thank you for the
question um I'm afraid that maybe you're
not maybe misinterpreting the original
law it is a 60-day notice of sale that
is all it is and it says that a landlord
if the the tenants come together and
make an offer the landlord will consider
that offer there's an extra piece which
if the it's amended would no longer be
referenced that said well the landl will
give a little extra time to get the
financing for that offer but ultimately
at its heart all it is is 60-day notice
of sale that's it or amended version 45
days that is all it is so that time
period gives them the opportunity to
make a decision whether or not to come
together and see if they can get
financing but that whether or not they
choose to do that is irrelevant they may
not choose to do that this is just
giving them notification of sale and
it's before it's 60 days before closing
which most of the time it take and maybe
not so much in this market but certainly
with multi-million dollar deals it
usually takes more than that to close
anyway because you have inspections and
all sorts of different processes in
there I'm G representative Miner then
representative Hicks and representative
paage thank you Mr chairman and I'm just
curious I I've been through the the
process with selling mobile home parks
I've done it three times
it is not actually that quick and
easy um especially when they're coming
back and saying you know we could use a
little more time this financing wasn't
working can we use a little more time
it's it really is a lot longer than that
process I don't know if that was out of
line or if I was supposed to even say
that but I have done it three times and
it's never been quick and easy and it's
although I'm grateful that they did
Co-op it was not easy and not fun not
fun at all represent Hicks yeah thank
you um this is why I was hoping we could
maybe retain this because it's been a
great discussion and I think um there is
room for compromise here so uh if people
would entertain that thought that maybe
we keep this around and not just itl it
that I'd be grateful thank you thank you
um represent
paig I was just going to follow up on
the comment um from my colleague from
Littleton um you know if if there is
desire or willingness to find a
compromise here where we're just talking
about notice I think the amendment that
Merill spoke to pushes in that direction
anyhow but if um the Republicans on
caucus are amable to the idea of
something that's more narrowly T
tailored just around the notice I think
that would be worth discussion well I
would say in response to that if the itl
motion fails then you're welcome to
offer another motion representative
Gibbs
thank you um I just um point out that I
would be open to a further amendment
that would remove the reference to the
opportunity to make an offer to the um
the opportunity to make an offer uh and
so that this is just purely notice to
remove the element of unfairness of the
tenant only finding out that the
building is being sold after there's a
new
owner representative Reed um and I'm
sorry I can't see all the way down but
the representative that said that you've
worked with three different uh
manufactured housing parks to sell them
um did I understand you correctly that
um not all of them went
Co-op go ahead yes that's correct okay
uh two one of them had co-oped out of
the three thank you and I think the
point that you Illustrated is a very
good point which is the sale takes a
long time usually longer than 60 days so
that notification period and again we
can say are they're allowed to make an
offer or not they are allowed to make an
offer that's as the chair very rightly
pointed out they're allowed to make an
offer at any time um but that 60 days
which gives them a little bit of time to
do that usually Falls within the period
of time it would take for the the seller
to go through the process with the
current um buyer anyway so if it takes
90 days with the current buyer then the
60 days is not a problem or 45 even less
so representative um
Daxton that makes no sense the if if I
if I have a property under contract with
a investor we'll call this this investor
person yes it might take 45 or 60 days
to do a transaction but I can't start
the transaction till I'm free to
transfer title so you're no yes that's
how that's not the that's that's not the
language of the bill and it's not it's
not fining works and that's how purchase
and sales work
yeah the final acceptance you may
respond I may yes um and I'll just pull
up the bill that is not the language the
successful language of the manufacturer
housing law thank you very much I
appreciate that and it's not the
language of the bill the language is
before uh a final unconditional
acceptance of any offer so that means
closing as in you can't go back it's
done so within within the offer within
the offer is contingent upon usually
things like inspection and other things
it's also contingent upon the law and if
the law says it has to be 60 days and
that's the part that's contingent upon
it representative Daxton go ahead and
respond why would my buyer want to spend
$2,000 on a commercial appraisal and God
knows how much money on inspections on a
deal that he doesn't know that he can
make that makes absolutely no
sense and that's okay representative
deont just for clarification as someone
who deals with pns is quite
frequently acceptance of an offer is
when two parties or more sign and now
you have an effective date there it's
not the sale of the property or at
closing acceptance of the offer the way
that this is worded because it says
acceptance of the offer for sale or
transfer so this would be prohibiting
anybody from signing an offer that's in
front of them you'd have to give notice
PRI to making that
acceptance representative Reed then
representative Gibbs representative d i
I appreciate your response but you're
skipping over the two very important and
very functional words that are in the
current law and have been working for 40
years that's final unconditional final
unconditional as in when you do an offer
it's usually contingent it's conditional
on things like inspection and what have
you final unconditional is when you are
done final done closing so that is what
this is referencing and that is the
actual practice that the manufactured
housing Parks go through in terms of the
other um comment that was made why would
my buyer go through paying for
inspections and what have you when they
aren't guaranteed that they'll have the
that's true of literally every buyer
everyone who makes an offer on a house
goes through that
process that's you don't know if you're
going to actually end up with it because
it's
conditional represent
Gibbs thank you just to clarify even if
the reference to the opportunity to make
an offer is removed from the bill the
tenants would still have the opportunity
to make an offer several people have
pointed out that opportunity always
exists anybody can make an offer to buy
something and the opportunity would
always exist so long as the property
hasn't actually already been sold so I'm
just trying to clarify that the amended
bill would be about
notice representative Reed a question of
the committee um we're spending a lot of
time discussing this so since we're no
longer the idea of the amendment no
longer directly referencing the
manufactured housing um statute that has
been successful would the committee
therefore be open to language around 60
days before close like just straight up
or 45 days before close um so why don't
we
um call the vote on the itl and see
where that goes and then if that fails
then we can discuss other options for
the
bill so at this point I'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role on this the
motion is itl representative Daxton
second by representative
Aaron Vice chairman Cole
yes representative Faxton yes
representative Aaron yes repes
representative booler yes representative
Dumont yes representative Grant yes
representative miles yes representative
Miner yes clerk reinford yes
Representative paig no representative
bores no representative Reed no
representative Gibbs no representative
Hicks no
representative Howland no Representative
hegner no representative Kerwin
no
chairman chairman Alexander
yes um so motion carries 10
to8 um representative Daxton I'm going
to have you write the majority report um
will there be a Minority
Report and what's the motion is it ought
to pass is amended or is it
retained otpa is the motion and can you
get me an amendment number for that can
you read off that amendment number the
Am
Number
96 That's The Minority Report is off to
pass as
amended okay next up I'm who who's
writing that um representative Reed Reed
okay thank you
okay next up I'm going to open up the
executive session on House Bill
558 and
recognize um representative baxton for a
motion I move
itl um is there a second representative
Dumont seconds it uh representative daon
would you like to speak to
that yes in most of the testimony there
was
significant questions brought up about
some of the legality of this this is
information that is readily available in
the public domain for the most part and
more importantly I believe that there is
a potential legal problem on the federal
level with this based upon the uh
2024 settlement between the National
Association of Realtors in the United
States of America wherein uh
compensation and the cost of things were
not to be made public and are in fact uh
considered non-public information so
there's that potential problem as well
but fundamentally the the the you you
heard from the registar the bill
achieves nothing particularly helpful uh
and the public does have access to the
same information as the supposed
landlord
class representative Gibbs thank you um
based on our earlier conversation I was
under the impression that borrowing
unusual circumstances we were not going
to exec bills on the same day as the
public
hearing um so perh house rules I noticed
um executive session is allowed on
pending legislation and I think this is
one of those bills um that seem
unworkable I did contact and confer with
the ranking member um just to notify him
that we're going to do this today so I
have two bills that we heard today that
I'd like to take care of today um for to
speed up the
process I understand that it's allowed
um obviously I understood that when the
vote was taken in in the house session
um it's just that I think it's a good
idea if we have a little time to think
about
it thank you other
comments seeing none
the motion is inexpedient to legislate
on House Bill
558 uh will the clerk call the role Vice
chairman Cole
yes representative Faxton
yes representative Aron yes
representative bullier yes
representative Dumont yes representative
Grant yes representative miles yes
representative minor yes clerk reinford
yes representative
Paige
no Representative boras no
representative Reed no representative
Gibbs no representative Hicks no
representative
Howland no Representative hegner no
representative Kerwin no chairman
Alexander yes
motion carries 10 to8 um itl
representative Thon will write the
majority report will there be a Minority
Report the motion will be to retain
okay okay so the last bill that I was
going to call today is the last one we
heard House Bill 623 relative to
prohibiting corporations from purchasing
single family homes for a certain amount
of time I'm going to recognize
representative Cole for a motion make a
motion inexpedient legislate is there a
second I second that represent bolo
seconds
discussion the bill has written as
problematic I think it has a long way to
go before it hits prime time so this
time it shouldn't go
forward representative
Paige I I share some concerns about this
bill um not going to support this itl
motion uh because I have a lot of
admiration for what it's trying to do
what it's trying to accomplish for
granite Staters um you know I think
there are some issues here I think the
multif family piece that's included in
there is probably problematic I think
the uh the points that repb Dumont
raised um about how this will impact
certain kinds of you know llc's and
other folks are significant I'd also
like to see us work on it personally um
so I'll be opposing the
itl representative Reed
also and I was a co-sponsor on the last
term one as well um acknowledge that the
language needs work however I never ever
support killing something I think it's
disingenuous actually to support killing
something because the language needs
work because if you agree with the
underlying intention you should do the
work that's why we're here that's why we
ask people to vote for us so if you
believe in the underlying intention that
humans should own homes and not
corporations then we should do the work
to fix the
language yeah I I fundamentally disagree
with the whole premise of the bill so
that's that's why I F that's fine but
that wasn't what I heard and I was
addressing this is like llc's are people
people own llc's like I mean this is so
broad-reaching and the fact that a local
municipality will take control of a
property I understand there's Preston
and some other areas but this is like Mr
chair I wasn't far out there I and I
think that's the answer I was trying to
coax which is the real intent of the
people who are voting to itl it's not oh
it's just unworkable we can't do it it's
we don't actually we want corporations
to own the homes and so well I I'm I'm
I'm gonna hesitate you to imply intent
on why we're voting the way we're voting
but I'm I'm what I'm saying the only
point that I was making and I wasn't
directing it at the chair but at the
comments I had heard already which is is
in General on any Bill anytime that
you're a legislator I think it's bad
faith to say well I agree with the
intent but I just don't want to do the
work I think we should do the work on
anything that we agree on the intent on
and so if if you don't like the intent
then just say that which the chair was
willing to do and I think the chair I
don't like the intent all right
representative Hicks then representative
Gibbs thank you um I just think that
voting on this so quickly is a reason I
cannot support the I representative
Gibbs um I'm not going to tell you why I
think anybody else is voting one way or
another I'm just going to tell you why
I'm going to vote no and it's for a
reason very similar to representative
Hicks that I think we should have taken
some time to think about this rather
than voting on it immediately after the
public
hearing thank
you representative
Aon uh I'm going to vote to itl this
bill because there's just too many
problems with it every mom and pop LLC
would be prohibited from buying a house
and so I I think there's a lot of flaws
to this bill representative um Dumont
then
bolo I would just like to say for me
personally I'm going to be voting to itl
and the reason for that being is I've
had more than one day to review this
bill uh we've all had so thank you
represent buolo uh I Echo representative
dumont's comments and I would also add
you know a lot of a lot has been said
well okay well we need to work on this
and that the fact is we only have so
much time in the session time is at a
premium time is you know of the essence
and we have a lot of really big issues
before us so the amount of time that
would take to try to fix this language
when there's already disagreements about
the fundamental premise I think we need
to economize our time and we need to
actually get good things done
representative
Reed well I understand time is
a a um a scarcity and we all have
bandwidth especially considering we're
not paid right so um having said that we
don't have all that many bills compared
to some committees and this is this is
the biggest issue and I don't think that
any of us should be asking going around
asking people to vote for us asking for
this position and this title unless
we're going to take this
seriously um now if you want to talk
about well do we want to include mom and
pop llc's because that's really honestly
the majority of owners are these llc's
that it's just one person that owns like
a bunch of different nine Maple Street
LLC um or do we want to include
nonprofits all of that is the work if
you don't agree with the underlying
intent as the chair has aptly stated
then say that don't say well you know we
could change this language but I don't
want to work and take the time to change
the language it's a huge issue 30 yes it
was like 1% of of of houses are owned by
Blackstone but 30% are owned by some
sort of corporate like it's not owned by
people and so it's a huge huge issue so
if if it's about the llc's or the
nonprofits or what's an entity or does
it go back to the municipal like let's
do the work I'm here for the work and
I'm getting paid the same as everybody
else here but if it's not that and it's
just actually we're fine with
corporations buying up all the houses
then fine say that that's my point okay
point taken so at this point I'm going
to to have the clerk call the role the
motion was itl on HB 623 representative
Cole second by representative buolo Vice
chairman Cole
yes representative Thaxton
yes representative Aaron yes
representative bullier
yes representative Dumont yes
representative Grant yes representative
miles yes representative Miner yes clerk
reinford yes Representative
paig no Representative boras no
representative Reed no representative
Gibbs no representative Hicks no
representative Howland no Representative
keger no representative Kerwin no
chairman Alexander yes so motion carries
10 to8 um I'm going to have
representative Cole write the majority
report and will there be a Minority
Report our motion will be to retain and
I don't know if I have a volunteer if I
don't I'll do it
but all right I'll do it Joe okay
represent the Minority Report um and the
motion will be to
retain okay so with that we finish up
all our business for today um plan on
having hearings next Tuesday I scheduled
all of mine that I'm PRI sponsoring in
Tuesday so the majority of them are
going to be run by representative Cole
but um you'll be in good hands and I'll
just sit back um any other comments or
anything to add to the committee before
we
adjourn Perfect all right we are Jed
have a good day everyone